Do you guys eat standing up at all like lunch or breakfast when you don't see the table? Wait, you mean like a horse sleeps? Does a horse sleep standing up or is that just a cow? That's a cow. That's a cow. No, I mean they eat, hey, where do you, Sean, you go, sorry, because you had, it seems like you had a thought about, are you doing a lot of standing at standing counters? I do. I do. I eat standing up a lot.
Do you guys eat standing up at all like lunch or breakfast when you don't see the table? Wait, you mean like a horse sleeps? Does a horse sleep standing up or is that just a cow? That's a cow. That's a cow. No, I mean they eat, hey, where do you, Sean, you go, sorry, because you had, it seems like you had a thought about, are you doing a lot of standing at standing counters? I do. I do. I eat standing up a lot.|||你们会站着吃东西吗，比如午饭或早饭，当你看不到桌子的时候？等等，你是说像马睡觉那样？马是站着睡觉的，还是只有牛才那样？那是牛。那是牛。不，我是说它们吃东西，嘿，你在哪，肖恩，你说，抱歉，因为你刚才，看起来你有个想法，你是不是经常站在立式柜台前？我是。我是。我经常站着吃饭。
Through open windows? What are you doing? Anyway, talk about being open. I love being open with you guys. Welcome to Smartless. What just happened? What happened? So wait, so when did you move into your new place? I moved in yesterday. I just got here. Wow!
Through open windows? What are you doing? Anyway, talk about being open. I love being open with you guys. Welcome to Smartless. What just happened? What happened? So wait, so when did you move into your new place? I moved in yesterday. I just got here. Wow!|||从开着的窗户？你在干什么？不管怎样，说到敞开心扉。我喜欢跟你们敞开心扉。欢迎收听 Smartless。刚刚怎么了？发生什么事了？等等，那你是什么时候搬进新地方的？我昨天搬的。我刚到这儿。哇！
Can you straighten out your fucking hat? You're not Justin Bieber. Dude, dude, hang on. First of all, I'm very young. I know. Okay. No. Well, you don't tell your face. Okay. Yeah.
Can you straighten out your fucking hat? You're not Justin Bieber. Dude, dude, hang on. First of all, I'm very young. I know. Okay. No. Well, you don't tell your face. Okay. Yeah.|||你能把你的破帽子戴正吗？你又不是贾斯汀·比伯。老兄，老兄，等等。首先，我很年轻。我知道。好吧。不。好吧，你那脸可看不出来。好吧。 yeah.
Honestly, why is it cocked? I just did it like that for one second. There. Thank you. It feels good to put it on the side like that. I do that too sometimes. Shut up, Sean. Fuck you. Thank you. It feels good to put it on the side like that. I do that too. Shut up, Sean That's a record for a shut up Sean
Honestly, why is it cocked? I just did it like that for one second. There. Thank you. It feels good to put it on the side like that. I do that too sometimes. Shut up, Sean. Fuck you. Thank you. It feels good to put it on the side like that. I do that too. Shut up, Sean That's a record for a shut up Sean|||说真的，它为什么是歪的？我刚刚那样弄了一秒钟。好了。谢谢。把帽子这样戴在旁边感觉挺好的。我有时候也会那样。闭嘴，肖恩。去你的。谢谢。把帽子这样戴在旁边感觉挺好的。我也那样。闭嘴，肖恩。这创下了“闭嘴肖恩”的纪录了。
Two minutes inside two minutes were already at shut up Sean. I love it miss you. Can't you I know we're gonna see each other tomorrow It's gummy city for me. Oh, chew it up. And suck it down. And then take a gummy? Yeah. Hey, so, Will, how's your new... First of all, congratulations, Will, on finishing an incredibly hard period of work. Let's go, great.
Two minutes inside two minutes were already at shut up Sean. I love it miss you. Can't you I know we're gonna see each other tomorrow It's gummy city for me. Oh, chew it up. And suck it down. And then take a gummy? Yeah. Hey, so, Will, how's your new... First of all, congratulations, Will, on finishing an incredibly hard period of work. Let's go, great.|||两分钟不到两分钟我们就在说闭嘴肖恩了。我太喜欢了，想你们。难道你——我知道我们明天就要见面了。对我来说这就是软糖之城。哦，嚼碎它。然后吸下去。然后再来颗软糖？对。嘿，威尔，你的新……首先，威尔，祝贺你完成了一段极其辛苦的工作期。太棒了，好极了。
What we have cooking in Hollywood's oven is undoubtedly a masterpiece. I'm going to call it right now. Yes, and I was there to witness the masterpiece. It was so good. There's a dash of Sean in it. Thank you, Sean. Which is more than enough.
What we have cooking in Hollywood's oven is undoubtedly a masterpiece. I'm going to call it right now. Yes, and I was there to witness the masterpiece. It was so good. There's a dash of Sean in it. Thank you, Sean. Which is more than enough.|||我们在好莱坞的烤箱里酝酿的作品无疑是一部杰作。我在此直接宣布了。是的，我当时就在场见证了这部杰作。太棒了。里面还有一点肖恩的风格。谢谢你，肖恩。这就足够了。
And a sprinkle of Scotty. Sean and Scotty were so great. Can I just tell you, having them around, it was so fun and I've seen a bunch of stuff and it's really, really good. This is a film, listener, that Will wrote and just finished acting in, directed by our friend Bradley Cooper,
And a sprinkle of Scotty. Sean and Scotty were so great. Can I just tell you, having them around, it was so fun and I've seen a bunch of stuff and it's really, really good. This is a film, listener, that Will wrote and just finished acting in, directed by our friend Bradley Cooper,|||再加上一点斯科特的点缀。肖恩和斯科特太棒了。我能告诉你吗，有他们在身边，真的太有趣了，而且我已经看过很多素材了，真的非常非常好。听众朋友们，这是一部由威尔编剧并刚刚演完、由我们的朋友布莱德利·库珀导演的电影，
who's also in it. On it. What a film, mate. What a guy. Oh, what a guy. Yeah, exactly, he was so guy. Well, what an eye. Yeah, exactly, he was so great. Yeah, he was great. Yeah, it was super fun.
who's also in it. On it. What a film, mate. What a guy. Oh, what a guy. Yeah, exactly, he was so guy. Well, what an eye. Yeah, exactly, he was so great. Yeah, he was great. Yeah, it was super fun.|||他也在里面。参与其中。多棒的电影啊，伙计。多棒的家伙。哦，多棒的家伙。对，没错，他太“家伙”了。哇，多好的眼光。对，没错，他太棒了。对，他太棒了。对，超级有趣。
And Jay, are you done with yours yet? No, I got another six weeks left. Oh wow, well that's not so bad. But that's also fun and going well. But you're having a good time and you're working your butt off too. I am, it's very, very hard. But don't try to deflect.
And Jay, are you done with yours yet? No, I got another six weeks left. Oh wow, well that's not so bad. But that's also fun and going well. But you're having a good time and you're working your butt off too. I am, it's very, very hard. But don't try to deflect.|||杰伊，你的搞定了吗？没有，我还剩六周。哦，哇，那倒也还行。但这也挺有趣并且进展顺利。不过你过得很开心，而且你也拼命工作了。我是的，非常非常辛苦。但别想转移话题。
You've just finished just like an incredibly large amount of work and it must feel nice to be done and you're back home in a new home. Your hat's kind of cocked and it's like, everything's happening. Well, I'm wearing it high. I'm thinking about, I'm like Von Dutch adjacent right now with my hat situation.
You've just finished just like an incredibly large amount of work and it must feel nice to be done and you're back home in a new home. Your hat's kind of cocked and it's like, everything's happening. Well, I'm wearing it high. I'm thinking about, I'm like Von Dutch adjacent right now with my hat situation.|||你刚刚完成了极其巨大的一大堆工作，做完的感觉一定很好，而且你回到了新家里。你的帽子有点歪，感觉就像，所有事情都在发生。嗯，我戴得很高。我在想，我现在的帽子风格大概和 Von Dutch 差不多吧。
Cause, listener, he's got long hair, and it's all kinda kinked and... Looking super sexy. I'm going old school with my flaked hat, you know what I mean? You must just be crushing ass out there, huh? Amen. Just walking around with that hairdo.
Cause, listener, he's got long hair, and it's all kinda kinked and... Looking super sexy. I'm going old school with my flaked hat, you know what I mean? You must just be crushing ass out there, huh? Amen. Just walking around with that hairdo.|||因为，听众朋友们，他留着长发，而且有点卷曲……看起来超级性感。我戴着那顶有褶皱的帽子走老派路线，你知道我的意思吗？你在外面一定迷倒了不少人吧？阿门。顶着那个发型到处走。
Can't wait for that headline, you know what I mean? How about we're all in the same city though for once. I'm so excited to see you guys. I feel like we haven't recorded one of these in a few weeks too. It's been a minute. Many weeks, yeah. It's been a minute and what do we got on the menu
Can't wait for that headline, you know what I mean? How about we're all in the same city though for once. I'm so excited to see you guys. I feel like we haven't recorded one of these in a few weeks too. It's been a minute. Many weeks, yeah. It's been a minute and what do we got on the menu|||等不及看到那个头条了，你知道我的意思吗？不过话说回来，我们终于难得都在同一个城市了。我好兴奋能见到你们。我觉得我们也有好几周没录制这个节目了。有一段时间了。好几个星期了，对。有一段时间了，我们菜单上有什么
for tomorrow night? Has anybody made a request yet? For food? Yeah. Can I make two guesses? Yeah. Well there are only two guesses. By the way, they're great, they're great guesses.
for tomorrow night? Has anybody made a request yet? For food? Yeah. Can I make two guesses? Yeah. Well there are only two guesses. By the way, they're great, they're great guesses.|||明天晚上的？有人点菜了吗？为了吃的？对。我能猜两个吗？可以。好吧，总共也只有两个猜测。顺便说一句，它们很棒，是非常棒的猜测。
They're great, they're always great. And if she's listening, listen. Those two meals are two of my favorite meals. No, they're the best. There's a reason they're on a heavy rotation. Yeah, we always have an unbelievable time in a delicious meal and we're very very lucky And I haven't been able to be there for a long time Willie you haven't been there for months and months and months
They're great, they're always great. And if she's listening, listen. Those two meals are two of my favorite meals. No, they're the best. There's a reason they're on a heavy rotation. Yeah, we always have an unbelievable time in a delicious meal and we're very very lucky And I haven't been able to be there for a long time Willie you haven't been there for months and months and months|||它们很棒，一直都很棒。如果她在听的话，听着。那两顿饭是我最喜欢的两顿饭。不，它们是最好的。它们被频繁翻牌是有原因的。是的，我们总是能度过一段令人难以置信的美好时光，享用美味的餐点，我们非常非常幸运。而且我已经很久没去那里了，威利，你已经好几个月好几个月没去了。
Yeah, January, I think yeah Yeah, I'm very excited. It's gonna be fun on the way back. I flew back yesterday. I thought Chicago, right? Yeah from Chicago. I stopped in and I saw a Yeah, from Chicago. I stopped in and I saw a play at my old high school with some friends that I was in that play with. They did, You Can't Take It With You, you know, that old play. And so all of a bunch of friends.
Yeah, I think yeah Yeah, I'm very excited. It's gonna be fun on the way back. I flew back yesterday. I thought Chicago, right? Yeah from Chicago. I stopped in and I saw a Yeah, from Chicago. I stopped in and I saw a play at my old high school with some friends that I was in that play with. They did, You Can't Take It With You, you know, that old play. And so all of a bunch of friends.|||对，我想是的。对，我很兴奋。在回来的路上会很有趣。我昨天飞回来的。我以为是芝加哥，对吧？对，从芝加哥。我顺道去看了——对，从芝加哥。我顺道去我以前的高中看了一场话剧，和我一起演过那场话剧的朋友们一起。他们演的是《浮生若梦》，你知道的，那部老话剧。所以一大群朋友。
What a show! Turns out you can take it with you. Yeah, is that wild? But wait a second, you went and saw a show at your high school, you're still in contact with the folks that run your high school theater program? No, no, friends, my friends that I was in theater with in high school, and my friend Amy and Rob and Shireen,
What a show! Turns out you can take it with you. Yeah, is that wild? But wait a second, you went and saw a show at your high school, you're still in contact with the folks that run your high school theater program? No, no, friends, my friends that I was in theater with in high school, and my friend Amy and Rob and Shireen,|||多精彩的演出！结果证明你还真能把它带走。对，是不是很疯狂？但等一下，你回高中看演出，你还和运营高中戏剧项目的人保持着联系吗？不，不，是朋友，我和高中一起搞戏剧的朋友，我的朋友艾米、罗布和希琳，
and Shireen I went to prom with, and she's like, so we're all like, let's go see the play that we were all a part of. Was she a beard situation? Yeah, 100%. Can I ask you this too? I actually thought that you were gonna say, I was in Chicago and I stopped to check in with,
and Shireen I went to prom with, and she's like, so we're all like, let's go see the play that we were all a part of. Was she a beard situation? Yeah, 100%. Can I ask you this too? I actually thought that you were gonna say, I was in Chicago and I stopped to check in with,|||我和希琳一起去过毕业舞会，她说，所以我们大家就说，去看看我们都曾参与过的话剧吧。她当时是你的挡箭牌吗？对，百分之百。我能问你个问题吗？我其实以为你要说，我在芝加哥，我顺便去拜访了——
I thought you were gonna say a piece of chocolate cake. I stopped to check in with Pertillo's. Yeah, Pertillo's, that's the name of the place. By the way, I did. I got off the plane. Shawnee, I'm always impressed, I don't know if that's the right word, with the amount of people you're still in contact with.
I thought you were gonna say a piece of chocolate cake. I stopped to check in with Pertillo's. Yeah, Pertillo's, that's the name of the place. By the way, I did. I got off the plane. Shawnee, I'm always impressed, I don't know if that's the right word, with the amount of people you're still in contact with.|||我还以为你要说一块巧克力蛋糕。我顺便去造访了 Pertillo's。对，Pertillo's，那就是那家店的名字。顺便说一句，我确实去了。我刚下飞机。肖妮，我总是对你至今仍保持联系的人数感到印象深刻，我不知道这词用得对不对。
I know, me too. From you. It speaks to what a great, genuine person you are. It really does. It really does. Yeah, yeah. Because on the surface you seem like such a world class a-hole.
I know, me too. From you. It speaks to what a great, genuine person you are. It really does. It really does. Yeah, yeah. Because on the surface you seem like such a world class a-hole.|||我知道，我也是。从你身上看。这说明你是一个多么棒、多么真诚的人。真的。确实如此。对，对。因为表面上看你简直是个世界级的混蛋。
Thank you, thank you Will. I was trying to figure out how to say it. Yeah, but then it turns out, no, you are such a caring and loving. Surprisingly nice. That's very sweet, look it, that's her, and that's my friend Rob, you are such a caring and loving. Surprisingly nice. That's very sweet. Look at that's her. Yeah.
Thank you, thank you Will. I was trying to figure out how to say it. Yeah, but then it turns out, no, you are such a caring and loving. Surprisingly nice. That's very sweet, look it, that's her, and that's my friend Rob, you are such a caring and loving. Surprisingly nice. That's very sweet. Look at that's her. Yeah.|||谢谢，谢谢你，威尔。我正琢磨着怎么说呢。是的，但结果证明，不，你是一个如此体贴和充满爱心的人。出奇地好。太贴心了，看，那是她，那是我的朋友罗布，你是一个如此体贴和充满爱心的人。出奇地好。太贴心了。看，那是她。对。
And that's my friend Rob and that's me, Prom. Oh my God. Anyway, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. The show was good? How was the show? The show was great. The kids were great. Did you have any notes for the person?
And that's my friend Rob and that's me, Prom. Oh my God. Anyway, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. The show was good? How was the show? The show was great. The kids were great. Did you have any notes for the person?|||那是我的朋友罗布，那是我，毕业舞会。哦，天哪。不管怎样，巴拉巴拉巴拉。巴拉巴拉巴拉。演出好看吗？演出怎么样？演出很棒。孩子们很棒。你对那个人有什么意见或建议吗？
I had one line. I had one line and it was, you're a right chief to have enough gunpowder down there to blow up the whole town. So when... Wait, do you say that with anxiety? Yes, like, have you just come back from a reconnaissance? Yeah, exactly. By the way, when I was in high school...
I had one line. I had one line and it was, you're a right chief to have enough gunpowder down there to blow up the whole town. So when... Wait, do you say that with anxiety? Yes, like, have you just come back from a reconnaissance? Yeah, exactly. By the way, when I was in high school...|||我有一句台词。我就一句台词，是：“长官，你真行，下面竟然有足够的火药把整个镇子都炸飞。”所以当……等等，你说这句话的时候带着焦虑吗？对，就像，你刚从侦察回来吗？对，完全是。顺便说一句，我上高中的时候……
Like kind of out of breath, you were right, chief. Totally, totally. And when the guy came on, because we sat in the bow... Do you remember the way you read it? Yeah, let me have it. Ready, and I think I just did it. No, just do it. Let's go.
Like kind of out of breath, you were right, chief. Totally, totally. And when the guy came on, because we sat in the bow... Do you remember the way you read it? Yeah, let me have it. Ready, and I think I just did it. No, just do it. Let's go.|||有点上气不接下气地说，长官，你真行。完全是，完全是。当那家伙上场时，因为我们坐在前排……你还记得你当时是怎么读的吗？对，让我来。准备，我觉得我刚才已经演了。不，直接演。开始吧。
You were right, Chief. They have enough gunpowder down there to blow them up. I hope you weren't laughing like that. This guy is nuts at the moment. But the guy that came out and said my line, I was like, woo! They clapped really hard. Oh my God. They were great. They're all great.
You were right, Chief. They have enough gunpowder down there to blow them up. I hope you weren't laughing like that. This guy is nuts at the moment. But the guy that came out and said my line, I was like, woo! They clapped really hard. Oh my God. They were great. They're all great.|||长官，你真行。他们下面有足够的火药把他们炸飞。我希望你当时不是那样笑的。这家伙现在疯了。但那个出来念我台词的家伙，我当时就想：哇！他们鼓掌鼓得好用力。哦，天哪。他们太棒了。他们都太棒了。
Anyway. Well, listen, you could have used some direction, which, and maybe you could have used direction from our guest today. Oh're all great anyway. Well listen you could have used some direction which and and maybe you could have I'll say. Direction from from our guest today. Oh nice Will. Yes because Segway alert. Segway alert because this is the guy who's become one of our more Accomplished directors that we have today. Oh no way. Not only is he prolific, but he is also a Fantastic director and what he does is and he came at it listen but he is also a fantastic director, and what he does is, and he came at it,
Anyway. Well, listen, you could have used some direction, which, and maybe you could have used direction from our guest today. Oh're all great anyway. Well listen you could have used some direction which and and maybe you could have I'll say. Direction from from our guest today. Oh nice Will. Yes because Segway alert. Segway alert because this is the guy who's become one of our more Accomplished directors that we have today. Oh no way. Not only is he prolific, but he is also a Fantastic director and what he does is and he came at it listen but he is also a fantastic director, and what he does is, and he came at it,|||不管怎样。听着，你本来可以接受一些导演指导的，也许你可以接受我们今天的嘉宾的指导。哦，反正大家都很棒。听着，你本可以接受一些指导的，也许你可以——我这么说吧——接受我们今天嘉宾的指导。哦，干得漂亮，威尔。是的，因为转折预警。转折预警，因为这位仁兄已经成为了我们当今时代最有成就的导演之一。哦，不会吧。他不仅高产，而且还是一位极其出色的导演，他的所作所为，他是从——听着，但他同时也是一位极其出色的导演，他的所作所为，他是从——
listen, again, he's one of those guys, once you name some of his credits, you're gonna go exactly who it is. But what I, and I know this guy, and I got to know him because he's worn a bunch of different hats in what we do. He, for many years, started as a stunt guy, I say stunt guy, stunt person.
listen, again, he's one of those guys, once you name some of his credits, you're gonna go exactly who it is. But what I, and I know this guy, and I got to know him because he's worn a bunch of different hats in what we do. He, for many years, started as a stunt guy, I say stunt guy, stunt person.|||听着，再说一次，他是那种人，只要你报出他的一些代表作，你就会立刻知道他是谁。但我——而且我认识这家伙，我认识他是因为他在我们这一行里扮演过各种不同的角色。他很多年前是从替身演员开始干起的，我说的是替身演员，特技演员。
And then he became a stunt coordinator, and then he became a director and a producer, and Jason, you already guessed it, because he did Deadpool 2, Hobbs and Shaw, Bullet Train, Fall Guy, it's my friend David Leitch. Oh my God, David Leitch, no way! The guy who knows what's going on. The second Oh my God, David Leach, no way. I told you, the second you say it,
And then he became a stunt coordinator, and then he became a director and a producer, and Jason, you already guessed it, because he did Deadpool 2, Hobbs and Shaw, Bullet Train, Fall Guy, it's my friend David Leitch. Oh my God, David Leitch, no way! The guy who knows what's going on. The second Oh my God, David Leach, no way. I told you, the second you say it,|||然后他成了特技指导，接着又成了导演和制片人，杰伊，你已经猜到了，因为他拍过《死侍2》、《霍布斯与肖》、《杀手疾风号》、《特技狂人》，他就是我的朋友大卫·雷奇。哦，天哪，大卫·雷奇，不会吧！这个深谙门道的家伙。第二幕——哦，天哪，大卫·雷奇，不会吧！我早就告诉你了，你一说出来——
because he's such a legend. Wow, this is so cool. Very good at what he does, everybody. He is very good, and one of the things, Dave, that I want to say, first of all, welcome to Smartless. Welcome. I'm excited, guys. Thanks for having us on. Yeah, I'm nervous.
because he's such a legend. Wow, this is so cool. Very good at what he does, everybody. He is very good, and one of the things, Dave, that I want to say, first of all, welcome to Smartless. Welcome. I'm excited, guys. Thanks for having us on. Yeah, I'm nervous.|||因为他是个传奇。哇，太酷了。各位，他在他做的事上非常厉害。他非常厉害，大卫，我想说的其中一件事，首先，欢迎来到 Smartless。欢迎。我很兴奋，伙计们。谢谢邀请我上节目。对，我很紧张。
Yeah. No, don't be nervous. One of the things I love about you, David, is that I knew you back when you were still coordinating, when I first met you and you were also second unit directing. Yeah. And you have not changed a bit.
Yeah. No, don't be nervous. One of the things I love about you, David, is that I knew you back when you were still coordinating, when I first met you and you were also second unit directing. Yeah. And you have not changed a bit.|||是的。不，别紧张。大卫，我喜欢你的一点是，我认识你的时候，你还在做特技指导，那是我第一次见你，你当时还在做第二摄制组导演。对。而且你一点都没变。
You've become like this huge director and you are still the same guy. You're still very hungry. You're still very normal. You're still very grounded. And so I really, it's a real testament, before we get going, everybody needs to know what a great dude you are.
You've become like this huge director and you are still the same guy. You're still very hungry. You're still very normal. You're still very grounded. And so I really, it's a real testament, before we get going, everybody needs to know what a great dude you are.|||你已经成了这么大牌的导演，但你还是当年的那个你。你依然很有进取心。你依然很随和。你依然很脚踏实地。所以我觉得，这真的是一个很好的证明，在我们开始之前，每个人都应该知道你是个多么棒的家伙。
I just want to say that off the bat. Well thanks, we had a great, thank you. Thank you. Well, you know, we had a great time on Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. We did, we did, we had a great time. David made me look really good because he shot all this stuff
I just want to say that off the bat. Well thanks, we had a great, thank you. Thank you. Well, you know, we had a great time on Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. We did, we did, we had a great time. David made me look really good because he shot all this stuff|||我开场就只想说这个。谢谢，我们度过了一段美好的——谢谢。谢谢。嗯，你知道的，我们在《忍者神龟》里度过了一段美好的时光。是的，是的，我们度过了一段美好的时光。大卫把我拍得特别帅，因为他拍了所有这些
of this 18-wheeler driving down a mountain, right? And so he went and he shot all this stuff, this insane 18-wheeler thing. They shot it like two months before and then like two months later, I got to just sit in the cab of a truck on a parking lot outside Steyner Studios in Brooklyn and just hyperventilate and pretend I was doing that.
of this 18-wheeler driving down a mountain, right? And so he went and he shot all this stuff, this insane 18-wheeler thing. They shot it like two months before and then like two months later, I got to just sit in the cab of a truck on a parking lot outside Steyner Studios in Brooklyn and just hyperventilate and pretend I was doing that.|||关于那辆十八轮大卡车开下山的镜头，对吧？所以他去拍了所有这些素材，那个疯狂的十八轮卡车镜头。他们提前大概两个月拍好，然后大约两个月后，我只要坐在布鲁克林斯泰纳制片厂外面停车场的一辆卡车驾驶室里，大口喘气，假装我正在经历这一切就行了。
But I want to say that was a great performance. Thank you. It was very brave, very brave. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Very brave. I had to get out of my Escalade, then get into the front cab of the thing. And then take off your warming coat.
But I want to say that was a great performance. Thank you. It was very brave, very brave. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Very brave. I had to get out of my Escalade, then get into the front cab of the thing. And then take off your warming coat.|||但我得说那是一场伟大的表演。谢谢。非常勇敢，非常勇敢。对，对，对。非常勇敢。我得从我的凯雷德里下来，然后钻进那个东西的前驾驶室。然后脱下你的保暖外套。
And take off at what time is lunch. But David, don't you think you have to be as prolific as you are and a bunch of directors that are as successful as you and Mr. Bateman here, don't you think you have to have that kind of personality that Will just described you are, which is a peacekeeper and like, you know, you can't get a hot head and everybody's, you know, keep everything in order because you can't have a hot head and everybody's, keep everything in order, because you can't have a temper, right?
And take off at what time is lunch. But David, don't you think you have to be as prolific as you are and a bunch of directors that are as successful as you and Mr. Bateman here, don't you think you have to have that kind of personality that Will just described you are, which is a peacekeeper and like, you know, you can't get a hot head and everybody's, you know, keep everything in order because you can't have a hot head and everybody's, keep everything in order, because you can't have a temper, right?|||然后脱下——几点吃午饭。但是大卫，你不觉得要想像你一样高产，还有像你和这里的贝特曼先生一样成功的一群导演，你不觉得你们必须具备威尔刚刚形容你的那种性格吗，也就是像个维和人员，你知道的，不能头脑发热，大家都得，你知道的，把一切都安排得井井有条，因为你不能头脑发热，大家都得把一切都安排得井井有条，因为你不能发脾气，对吧？
Well, I mean, there are directors that have it, that are prolific. There's plenty that have made it work. That I've worked with as a stuntman or a department head. Look, I was really lucky. I got to mentor under a lot of great directors. You got to see what worked for you and what doesn't work for you.
Well, I mean, there are directors that have it, that are prolific. There's plenty that have made it work. That I've worked with as a stuntman or a department head. Look, I was really lucky. I got to mentor under a lot of great directors. You got to see what worked for you and what doesn't work for you.|||嗯，我的意思是，有些导演确实有这种性格，他们也很高产。有很多人都成功做到了这一点。我作为特技演员或部门负责人时和他们合作过。听着，我很幸运。我曾在许多优秀的导演手下学习。你能看到什么对你有用，什么对你没用。
And being an asshole really doesn't work for me. No, it doesn't work for me. It doesn't, you would not wear asshole well. It is interesting, isn't it? Like a lot of people don't realize that directors don't work with other directors. So they don't know whether what they're doing is good
And being an asshole really doesn't work for me. No, it doesn't work for me. It doesn't, you would not wear asshole well. It is interesting, isn't it? Like a lot of people don't realize that directors don't work with other directors. So they don't know whether what they're doing is good|||而当一个混蛋对我来说真的行不通。不，对我来说行不通。行不通，你可不适合当混蛋。这挺有意思的，不是吗？比如很多人没有意识到，导演是不会和其他导演一起工作的。所以他们不知道自己做的是好
or bad or efficient or not. Or, you know, and so actors or cameramen or really anybody on the set has the opportunity to sort of cherry pick from, you know, a bunch of directors that how to do it if they get a chance to do it. And so David, can you mention any that you've picked some great points from?
or bad or efficient or not. Or, you know, and so actors or cameramen or really anybody on the set has the opportunity to sort of cherry pick from, you know, a bunch of directors that how to do it if they get a chance to do it. And so David, can you mention any that you've picked some great points from?|||还是坏，是高效还是低效。或者，你知道的，所以演员、摄像师或者片场真正任何其他人，都有机会从各种导演身上精挑细选出该怎么做，如果他们有机会去做的话。所以大卫，你能提到几个你从他们身上学到很多精髓的导演吗？
Yeah, I mean I worked with the Wachowskis for a long time. Oh yeah. And they, you know. On the Matrix movies. On the Matrix movies. Tracy, Tracy. And then after that we did V for Vendetta, we did Ninja Assassin, the classic Ninja Assassin.
Yeah, I mean I worked with the Wachowskis for a long time. Oh yeah. And they, you know. On the Matrix movies. On the Matrix movies. Tracy, Tracy. And then after that we did V for Vendetta, we did Ninja Assassin, the classic Ninja Assassin.|||可以，我的意思是，我和沃卓斯基姐妹合作了很长时间。哦，是的。他们，你知道的。在《黑客帝国》系列里。在《黑客帝国》系列里。翠西，翠西。然后在那之后我们拍了《V字仇杀队》，我们拍了《忍者刺客》，经典的《忍者刺客》。
But we did a lot of films and there's a precision to what they do, there's the homework that they do to be prepared, all of that stuff. And they really build a family with their department heads and they're really close. And they allow their department heads to be creative and bring them ideas. And that's where I really enjoy it.
But we did a lot of films and there's a precision to what they do, there's the homework that they do to be prepared, all of that stuff. And they really build a family with their department heads and they're really close. And they allow their department heads to be creative and bring them ideas. And that's where I really enjoy it.|||但我们拍了很多电影，他们做事有一种精确性，他们为了做好准备而做足了功课，诸如此类。他们真的与各部门负责人建立了一个像家庭一样的紧密关系。他们允许各部门负责人发挥创造力并向他们提出想法。这正是我非常喜欢的地方。
I think there's other directors that are like- That collaborative. Yeah, the collaborative spirit of a director, whereas especially coming from production, you want your ideas to be heard. You design a sequence as a stunt coordinator, you wanna be heard. That kinda goes to Jason.
I think there's other directors that are like- That collaborative. Yeah, the collaborative spirit of a director, whereas especially coming from production, you want your ideas to be heard. You design a sequence as a stunt coordinator, you wanna be heard. That kinda goes to Jason.|||我觉得还有其他导演是——那种协作精神。是的，导演的协作精神，特别是如果你出身于制作部门，你会希望自己的想法被听到。作为特技指导，你设计了一个动作场面，你会希望自己的想法被听到。这有点说到杰伊心坎里了。
Jason, it's interesting the point you make. Both of you guys became directors, but you came from, Jason, you's interesting the point you make. Both of you guys became directors, but you came from, Jason, you were an actor for many years since you were a kid, and then you came to it, so you got to witness and cherry pick pieces as you went and bring it into, and David, you started as a stunt performer and then coordinator, so you also got to work under,
Jason, it's interesting the point you make. Both of you guys became directors, but you came from, Jason, you's interesting the point you make. Both of you guys became directors, but you came from, Jason, you were an actor for many years since you were a kid, and then you came to it, so you got to witness and cherry pick pieces as you went and bring it into, and David, you started as a stunt performer and then coordinator, so you also got to work under,|||杰伊，你提出的观点很有意思。你们俩都成了导演，但你来自——杰伊，你提出的观点很有意思。你们俩都成了导演，但你来自——杰伊，你从小当了很多年演员，然后才走上这条路，所以你在经历的过程中得以见证并精挑细选各种片段，并将其带入其中；而大卫，你是从特技演员做起，然后成为特技指导，所以你也曾在……手下工作过，
whereas, Jason, as you were mentioning, a lot of directors who start as directors don't have that breadth of experience working with directors. You guys did. To know how to manage personalities. To know how to collaborate, right? Do you think there's something to that?
whereas, Jason, as you were mentioning, a lot of directors who start as directors don't have that breadth of experience working with directors. You guys did. To know how to manage personalities. To know how to collaborate, right? Do you think there's something to that?|||然而，杰伊，正如你刚才所说，许多一开始就是导演的导演并没有与各种导演合作过的丰富经验。你们俩有。知道如何管理不同性格的人。知道如何合作，对吧？你觉得这其中有什么门道吗？
Yeah, I do, David, and you were kind of touching on it that you get exposed to a few work environments, sets that have that collaborative spirit that you get exposed to a few work environments, sets that have that collaborative spirit or that we're just basically like to minimize it. It's sort of a good vibe. And what that yields is just a better product and it's applicable to any industry where, and I've said this before,
Yeah, I do, David, and you were kind of touching on it that you get exposed to a few work environments, sets that have that collaborative spirit that you get exposed to a few work environments, sets that have that collaborative spirit or that we're just basically like to minimize it. It's sort of a good vibe. And what that yields is just a better product and it's applicable to any industry where, and I've said this before,|||是的，我同意，大卫，你刚才也提到了这一点，你接触过一些工作环境、片场，它们拥有那种协作精神——你接触过一些工作环境、片场，它们拥有那种协作精神，或者我们基本上喜欢将其简化。这算是一种良好的氛围。而这带来的就是一个更好的作品，这适用于任何行业，就像我以前说过的那样，
I apologize to anyone who's heard this, but no one gets fired for doing 75%. You can hold your job for 40 years if you deliver 75%. That's what kind of people expect. But if you want that extra 25% from people, they've gotta feel a little bit of ownership, a little bit of buy-in, a little bit of, you know, equity in the process. And that comes from people feeling like they kind of...
I apologize to anyone who's heard this, but no one gets fired for doing 75%. You can hold your job for 40 years if you deliver 75%. That's what kind of people expect. But if you want that extra 25% from people, they've gotta feel a little bit of ownership, a little bit of buy-in, a little bit of, you know, equity in the process. And that comes from people feeling like they kind of...|||向听过这话的人道歉，但没有人会因为只做到 75% 而被解雇。如果你只交付 75% 的成果，你可以在同一岗位上干 40 年。大家期望的也就是这种水平。但如果你想从人们身上榨取额外的 25%，他们就必须对这个过程产生一点主人翁意识、一点认同感、一点，你知道的，股权般的投入感。而这来自于人们觉得他们某种程度上……
It's partly theirs. It's like if it's your house, you put a coaster underneath your drink without even being asked to. But if it's not your house, you might put your drink on the wood table and leave a ring. You don't really give a fuck. You're going to drive home. So if you let people feel like they're a part of the process, you get that extra bit and then the product really soars.
It's partly theirs. It's like if it's your house, you put a coaster underneath your drink without even being asked to. But if it's not your house, you might put your drink on the wood table and leave a ring. You don't really give a fuck. You're going to drive home. So if you let people feel like they're a part of the process, you get that extra bit and then the product really soars.|||这部分属于他们。这就好比如果是你自己的房子，不用别人提醒，你就会在杯子底下垫个杯垫。但如果这不是你的房子，你可能会把饮料直接放在木桌上，留下一圈水渍。你根本不在乎。反正你要开车回家。所以，如果你让人们觉得他们是这个过程的一部分，你就能得到那额外的成果，然后作品就会真正腾飞。
Especially in what we do. That's really well said. And I think that's really, really long said. That's really long said. Yeah. And I think it applies to many jobs, Jason. I think it's true though. So thank you.
Especially in what we do. That's really well said. And I think that's really, really long said. That's really long said. Yeah. And I think it applies to many jobs, Jason. I think it's true though. So thank you.|||特别是在我们这行里。这话真精辟。我觉得这也说得太长、太啰嗦了。这真的太啰嗦了。对。而且我觉得它适用于很多工作，杰伊。不过我觉得这是真的。所以谢谢你。
David, thoughts on that? No, I mean, it's 100% true. I mean, again, like having been on set, my entire adult life as a performer or a department head, it just, you wanna be included. And then being in the director chair and knowing all those people are there to make you look good, you take the good ideas and then you steal all the credit.
David, thoughts on that? No, I mean, it's 100% true. I mean, again, like having been on set, my entire adult life as a performer or a department head, it just, you wanna be included. And then being in the director chair and knowing all those people are there to make you look good, you take the good ideas and then you steal all the credit.|||大卫，对此有什么看法？不，我的意思是，百分之百是真的。我的意思是，话说回来，作为表演者或部门负责人，我的整个成年生活都在片场度过，你会希望自己被包容。然后当你坐在导演椅上，知道所有人都在那里为了让你出彩时，你就会采纳好的想法，然后把所有的功劳都据为己有。
That's true. That's nice. But David, so I mean, when you look at your, just your, first of all, your resume as a director is impressive enough considering the films that you've made so far as a director, but the films that you performed as, performed in, Fight Club, I mean, this is one of the great,
That's true. That's nice. But David, so I mean, when you look at your, just your, first of all, your resume as a director is impressive enough considering the films that you've made so far as a director, but the films that you performed as, performed in, Fight Club, I mean, this is one of the great,|||确实如此。这很棒。但大卫，我的意思是，当你回顾你的——首先，考虑到你作为导演迄今为止所拍摄的电影，你作为导演的简历已经足够令人印象深刻了，但你参与表演、参演过的电影，《搏击俱乐部》，我的意思是，这是一部伟大的作品——
that's a classic, people often reference it, especially dudes, as their favorite film of all time. You were Brad's stunt double in Fight Club, is that true? I was, but it was kind of like one of those movies where you're not doing a lot. When you think about it, it's funny, it's like the name is Fight Club, and then you go back and watch the film,
that's a classic, people often reference it, especially dudes, as their favorite film of all time. You were Brad's stunt double in Fight Club, is that true? I was, but it was kind of like one of those movies where you're not doing a lot. When you think about it, it's funny, it's like the name is Fight Club, and then you go back and watch the film,|||那是一部经典，人们经常把它——尤其是男人们——奉为他们有史以来最喜欢的电影。你在《搏击俱乐部》里当过布拉德的替身，是真的吗？我是当过，但这有点像那种你不用干太多活的电影。仔细想想，这挺搞笑的，就像它的名字叫《搏击俱乐部》，然后你回头去看这部电影，
I actually watched it a couple months ago. There's only like three fight sequences in it. But what we were doing, and you often do as a stunt performer, is train the actors. So we were training the actors for a long time, sort of in this messy style of fighting, and then I might have doubled Brad on two or three little moments.
I actually watched it a couple months ago. There's only like three fight sequences in it. But what we were doing, and you often do as a stunt performer, is train the actors. So we were training the actors for a long time, sort of in this messy style of fighting, and then I might have doubled Brad on two or three little moments.|||我其实几个月前刚看过。里面大概只有三个打斗场面。但我们当时在做的工作——特技演员经常做的那样——是训练演员。所以我们花很长时间训练演员这种略显凌乱的格斗风格，然后我可能在两三个小镜头里给布拉德当过替身。
Right. Because at that time he was like super fit dude. By the way, still super fit. Still super fit, yeah. The guy's ripped. I know, I know. Cool, you guys. By the way, Dave, these guys know nobody loves Brad more than me.
Right. Because at that time he was like super fit dude. By the way, still super fit. Still super fit, yeah. The guy's ripped. I know, I know. Cool, you guys. By the way, Dave, these guys know nobody loves Brad more than me.|||没错。因为他当时是个身材极其健美的家伙。顺便说一句，现在依然超级健美。依然超级健美，是的。那家伙肌肉线条太棒了。我知道，我知道。酷毙了，伙计们。顺便说一句，戴夫，这些人知道没有人比我更爱布拉德了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So everybody loves him. We all do. He's an awesome human being. Yeah, I loves him. We all do. He's an awesome human being. Yeah, I love him. And yeah, so it really was like one of those movies where I was working a lot, but we weren't, the stunts I had to do were like very, very simple.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So everybody loves him. We all do. He's an awesome human being. Yeah, I loves him. We all do. He's an awesome human being. Yeah, I love him. And yeah, so it really was like one of those movies where I was working a lot, but we weren't, the stunts I had to do were like very, very simple.|||对，对，对。所以大家都爱他。我们都爱。他是个了不起的人。对，我爱他。我们都爱。他是个了不起的人。对，我爱他。是的，所以这确实就像那种我工作很忙，但我们——我需要做的特技非常非常简单的电影。
Although I do remember one great, this goes back to Fincher being the sort of like perfectionist that he is. I had to throw the Ed Norton stunt double down that set of stairs at the end of the movie. Sure. 12 times. No way.
Although I do remember one great, this goes back to Fincher being the sort of like perfectionist that he is. I had to throw the Ed Norton stunt double down that set of stairs at the end of the movie. Sure. 12 times. No way.|||不过我还真记得一件很棒的事，这要归咎于芬奇那种精益求精的完美主义性格。在电影结尾，我得把爱德华·诺顿的替身演员从那段楼梯上扔下去。当然。扔了 12 次。不可能吧。
12 times. 12 takes. No way. And I ran into David, you know, this was like a couple years ago, and I ran into him and I asked him like, hey, what take did you use? And he's like, oh yeah, take two.
12 times. 12 takes. No way. And I ran into David, you know, this was like a couple years ago, and I ran into him and I asked him like, hey, what take did you use? And he's like, oh yeah, take two.|||12次。拍了 12 条。不会吧。我遇到大卫的时候——你知道的，大概是几年前吧——我碰到了他，我问他：“嘿，你最后用了第几条？”他回答说：“哦，对了，第二条。”
No. No, I. No way. Seriously. Oh yeah. 100%. So, while we're on, who is one of my favorite, favorite directors of all time, David Fincher,
No. No, I. No way. Seriously. Oh yeah. 100%. So, while we're on, who is one of my favorite, favorite directors of all time, David Fincher,|||不会吧。不，我。绝不可能。说真的。哦，是的。百分之百。所以，顺便提到我最最喜欢的导演之一——大卫·芬奇，
his level of specificity and precision does require a lesser amount, perhaps, of kind of, not contribution, but, or even collaboration. I'm not sure what the right word would be, but he knows exactly what he wants. And so, the sort of the arena for, hey, well, what do you guys think? You know, how should we do it? Like, there's a great deal of planning and precision going into every shot that he's doing. And so how do you recommend, even in other industries,
his level of specificity and precision does require a lesser amount, perhaps, of kind of, not contribution, but, or even collaboration. I'm not sure what the right word would be, but he knows exactly what he wants. And so, the sort of the arena for, hey, well, what do you guys think? You know, how should we do it? Like, there's a great deal of planning and precision going into every shot that he's doing. And so how do you recommend, even in other industries,|||他在具体细节和精确度上的要求，或许确实需要较少程度的某种——与其说是贡献，不如说是协作。我不知道用什么词来形容最合适，但他非常清楚自己想要什么。因此，那种“嘿，大家觉得呢？你知道的，我们该怎么做？”的讨论空间——他的每一个镜头都倾注了大量的计划和精准度。所以你觉得，即使在其他行业中，你如何建议——
room for other people to fit into that? Yeah, their own ideas. I mean, with David, I think you buy into the vision, right? And so I think part of the excitement with his crew is you know the vision is so strong that you want to make sure you're providing the details for it. And so again, if you're a professional
room for other people to fit into that? Yeah, their own ideas. I mean, with David, I think you buy into the vision, right? And so I think part of the excitement with his crew is you know the vision is so strong that you want to make sure you're providing the details for it. And so again, if you're a professional|||给其他人留下融入的空间？是的，让他们发挥自己的想法。我的意思是，对于大卫，我觉得你是认同他的愿景，对吧？所以我认为和他的团队合作的兴奋点之一在于，你知道他的愿景是如此强烈，以至于你想确保自己为之提供各种细节。所以再说一次，如果你是一个专业人士，
and you love this business and you get to work with somebody who has this really strong vision, then you ratchet the gear and looking in that way and like, okay, how can I service this vision? I mean. You're doing a lot of that though too. Like, you know, Bullet Train is,
and you love this business and you get to work with somebody who has this really strong vision, then you ratchet the gear and looking in that way and like, okay, how can I service this vision? I mean. You're doing a lot of that though too. Like, you know, Bullet Train is,|||并且热爱这个行业，你有机会和这样一个拥有强烈愿景的人合作，你就会调整状态，用那种方式看待问题，心想：“好吧，我该如何为这个愿景服务？”我是说。不过你其实也经常这么干。比如，你知道的，《杀手疾风号》是——
I got the title right? Yeah. I mean, there was so much incredible technical execution on that. That like, there's no room for fucking, hey guys, let's all kind of figure this out. You know, we'll just rehearse until lunch and then we'll just shoot after lunch.
I got the title right? Yeah. I mean, there was so much incredible technical execution on that. That like, there's no room for fucking, hey guys, let's all kind of figure this out. You know, we'll just rehearse until lunch and then we'll just shoot after lunch.|||我没记错片名吧？对。我的意思是，那里面有太多令人难以置信的技术执行了。以至于根本没有时间去他妈的搞什么“嘿，伙计们，让我们一起来琢磨琢磨吧”。你知道的，我们排练到吃午饭，然后午饭后直接开拍。
Let's just, it's like, no, you coming in with a plan, you know, exactly what, so. Well, I would say this, sorry to interrupt, but I think that that was a mixture of those two styles. I think, you know, I had shot listed that movie with Jonathan Sela and we were very, very precise, but we allowed for, like when you look at Aaron Taylor Johnson and Brian Terry Henry, they're playing these
Let's just, it's like, no, you coming in with a plan, you know, exactly what, so. Well, I would say this, sorry to interrupt, but I think that that was a mixture of those two styles. I think, you know, I had shot listed that movie with Jonathan Sela and we were very, very precise, but we allowed for, like when you look at Aaron Taylor Johnson and Brian Terry Henry, they're playing these|||我们只会——就像是，不，你是带着计划来的，你确切地知道什么，所以。嗯，我会这么说，抱歉打断一下，但我觉得那是这两种风格的结合。我觉得，你知道的，我和乔纳森·塞拉一起为那部电影做好了分镜头脚本，我们非常非常精准，但我们也留出了空间，就像你看看亚伦·泰勒-约翰逊和布莱恩·泰瑞·亨利，他们扮演的这些——
Levin and Tangerine. When I was in my setups, I let them go. Like they were just brilliant and I was just like rolling like, you know, like, and just mining for gold. So the composition and the editorial style and like all of the production design, like that was really my department heads and we curated it and we had a plan going in.
Levin and Tangerine. When I was in my setups, I let them go. Like they were just brilliant and I was just like rolling like, you know, like, and just mining for gold. So the composition and the editorial style and like all of the production design, like that was really my department heads and we curated it and we had a plan going in.|||莱蒙和橘子。在我的布景里，我放手让她们自由发挥。他们简直才华横溢，而我当时就像是在开机拍摄，你知道的，就像是在淘金。所以构图、剪辑风格以及所有的制作设计，实际上都是由我的部门负责人和我们共同策划的，我们在开拍前就有了计划。
But we let the actors riff a lot. Right, but once you get into the action sequences or stuff where the camera's being the performer, you've gotta keep them somewhat reined in, they gotta toe the marks, they gotta make sure their look doesn't turn until the camera gets around. Like, they need to be good soldiers.
But we let the actors riff a lot. Right, but once you get into the action sequences or stuff where the camera's being the performer, you've gotta keep them somewhat reined in, they gotta toe the marks, they gotta make sure their look doesn't turn until the camera gets around. Like, they need to be good soldiers.|||但我们让演员有很多即兴发挥的空间。没错，但一旦进入动作场面或者摄影机充当表演者的镜头时，你必须在某种程度上约束他们，他们必须踩准标记，必须确保在摄影机转过来之前眼神不乱转。就像，他们得当好听话的士兵。
And Jay, as you probably know, and David, we've talked about it, you made that film under very tough circumstances. It was right during the pandemic. And it takes place in Japan and you guys shot it in Culver City, primarily. Yeah. Totally. I didn't know that.
And Jay, as you probably know, and David, we've talked about it, you made that film under very tough circumstances. It was right during the pandemic. And it takes place in Japan and you guys shot it in Culver City, primarily. Yeah. Totally. I didn't know that.|||杰伊，正如你可能知道的，大卫，我们也聊过，你是在非常艰难的环境下拍摄那部电影的。那正值疫情期间。故事发生在日本，而你们主要是在卡尔弗城拍摄的。对。完全是。我不知道这一点。
Yeah, we shot it, it was right height of the pandemic, before the vaccine and we were green lit and we were actually getting ready to like, sort of prep it for Tokyo and we were going to go shoot it on location. And then it's like, they we were gonna go shoot it on location, and then it's like, they decided they wanted to do it, but they're gonna do it, can I do a version on stage?
Yeah, we shot it, it was right height of the pandemic, before the vaccine and we were green lit and we were actually getting ready to like, sort of prep it for Tokyo and we were going to go shoot it on location. And then it's like, they we were gonna go shoot it on location, and then it's like, they decided they wanted to do it, but they're gonna do it, can I do a version on stage?|||对，我们拍摄的时候，正处于疫情最严重的时期，在疫苗出来之前，我们项目获批了，我们当时实际上正准备为东京做筹备，打算去实地拍摄。然后就变成——他们本来打算去实地拍摄，接着就变成——他们决定要拍，但他们要这么拍：我能在摄影棚里拍一个版本吗？
And so... Well, wait, you weren't, but you had to assume that a lot of that was gonna be a build, right? Like, you weren't gonna shoot it on a practical train, all that stuff, were you? No, no, no, but I really wanted to go to Japan and like get some, you know, some real environments, and like, you know, and real grit and texture, I really wanted to go to Japan and get some real environments
And so... Well, wait, you weren't, but you had to assume that a lot of that was gonna be a build, right? Like, you weren't gonna shoot it on a practical train, all that stuff, were you? No, no, no, but I really wanted to go to Japan and like get some, you know, some real environments, and like, you know, and real grit and texture, I really wanted to go to Japan and get some real environments|||所以……嗯，等等，你不是——但你肯定料到很大一部分都要靠搭景搭建，对吧？比如，你不可能在一辆真正的火车上拍摄，诸如此类，对吧？不，不，不，但我真的很想去日本，获取一些，你知道的，真实的实景环境，还有，你知道的，真实的颗粒感和质感，我真的很想去日本获取一些真实的实景环境
and real grit and texture. And even the tone of the movie is now completely different because I'm like, okay, we're going to shoot it on stage. What's the anime version of this film? And then I think we did a big pivot with the production design and the music and the costumes. And I'm like, I'm going to make this sort of an anime graphic novel movie,
and real grit and texture. And even the tone of the movie is now completely different because I'm like, okay, we're going to shoot it on stage. What's the anime version of this film? And then I think we did a big pivot with the production design and the music and the costumes. And I'm like, I'm going to make this sort of an anime graphic novel movie,|||和真实的颗粒感与质感。甚至连电影的基调现在也完全不同了，因为我在想：“好吧，既然我们要在一个封闭摄影棚里拍摄，这部电影的动漫版会是什么样？”然后我觉得我们在制作设计、音乐和服装上做了一个巨大的转变。我就想：我要把它拍成那种动漫图形小说风格的电影，
because we really have one big sound stage we can do it on. But you knew you were going to go with a splinter unit or a second unit or whatever, get all the exteriors and the establishing, yes. And actually we did that crazy enough during the pandemic on WhatsApp. Yeah.
because we really have one big sound stage we can do it on. But you knew you were going to go with a splinter unit or a second unit or whatever, get all the exteriors and the establishing, yes. And actually we did that crazy enough during the pandemic on WhatsApp. Yeah.|||因为我们确实有一个很大的录音棚可以在里面拍。但你知道你会带一个分摄组或第二摄制组之类的，去拍摄所有的外景和建立镜头，是的。事实上，疯狂的是，我们在疫情期间通过 WhatsApp 就把这事儿给办了。对。
What do you mean? I had a cinematographer, I know. This is the greatest, I love this story. Cinematographer in Japan, and a first AD in Japan, and we had them for weeks scouting, sending location photos, sending video, because no one was allowed in Japan. You couldn't travel there.
What do you mean? I had a cinematographer, I know. This is the greatest, I love this story. Cinematographer in Japan, and a first AD in Japan, and we had them for weeks scouting, sending location photos, sending video, because no one was allowed in Japan. You couldn't travel there.|||什么意思？我当时有个摄影师，我知道。这是最棒的，我超爱这个故事。日本有个摄影师，日本还有个第一副导演，我们让他们连续几周进行堪景，发送外景照片，发送视频，因为当时没有人被允许进入日本。你根本无法去那里旅行。
Oh, wow. It was like there was a lockdown. Oh, so you did it through. We like there was a lockdown. So we did it all the plate photography we did with a remote unit and I would get up in two in the morning and get on WhatsApp and watch on a camera. No way. That's crazy. So he's directing remotely from the state through WhatsApp. And you're like, yeah, maybe frame it up a little bit.
Oh, wow. It was like there was a lockdown. Oh, so you did it through. We like there was a lockdown. So we did it all the plate photography we did with a remote unit and I would get up in two in the morning and get on WhatsApp and watch on a camera. No way. That's crazy. So he's directing remotely from the states through WhatsApp. And you're like, yeah, maybe frame it up a little bit.|||哦，哇。感觉就像封城了一样。哦，所以你是通过——我们就像封城了一样。所以我们所有的底片摄影都是通过远程小组完成的，我每天凌晨两点起床，登录 WhatsApp 在摄像头上观看。不可能吧。太疯狂了。所以他是通过 WhatsApp 从美国进行远程导演的。而你会说：“对，把构图稍微调整一下。”
Yeah, that's crazy. You know what I mean? Like that's amazing. So your video tap was through WhatsApp as well or was there another piece of software? No, we had another piece of software to give us the video and I can't remember what it was exactly. That's so insane. It was crazy.
Yeah, that's crazy. You know what I mean? Like that's amazing. So your video tap was through WhatsApp as well or was there another piece of software? No, we had another piece of software to give us the video and I can't remember what it was exactly. That's so insane. It was crazy.|||对，太疯狂了。你知道我的意思吗？这太神奇了。所以你的视频监看信号也是通过 WhatsApp 传输的，还是有别的软件？不，我们有另一个软件来给我们传输视频，我记不清具体是什么了。太离谱了。简直疯狂。
We'll be right back. And now back to the show. So we've never had a stunt person on before, and I'm fascinated with that life and why you chose it, and what was the first, like, you know, I just watched Smokey and the Band, and I was like, that guy was a stunt guy, you know, Hal Needham.
We'll be right back. And now back to the show. So we've never had a stunt person on before, and I'm fascinated with that life and why you chose it, and what was the first, like, you, I just watched Smokey and the Band, and I was like, that guy was a stunt guy, you know, Hal Needham.|||我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。我们以前从未邀请过特技演员上节目，我对那种生活以及你为什么选择它充满了好奇，还有最初是什么——比如，我刚刚看了《卡车司警》，当时我就想，那个家伙是个特技演员，你知道的，哈尔·尼达姆。
Hal Needham. What's that? Yeah. Hal Needham. Legend. If anybody needs him, Hal does. So, you know, the like what makes you want to do that? Because you get-
Hal Needham. What's that? Yeah. Hal Needham. Legend. If anybody needs him, Hal does. So, you know, the like what makes you want to do that? Because you get-|||哈尔·尼达姆。怎么了？对。哈尔·尼达姆。传奇人物。如果谁需要他，哈尔一定行。所以，你知道的，是什么让你想去干这个？因为你——
How does somebody wake up one day and go, hey, you know what I'm doing? I'm gonna beat the shit out of myself. Yeah. I hope somebody throws me down the stairs today. Yeah, and don't you just, aren't you constantly aching? Anyway, go ahead. Well, I actually, I am a little achy, I'm not gonna lie,
How does somebody wake up one day and go, hey, you know what I'm doing? I'm gonna beat the shit out of myself. Yeah. I hope somebody throws me down the stairs today. Yeah, and don't you just, aren't you constantly aching? Anyway, go ahead. Well, I actually, I am a little achy, I'm not gonna lie,|||一个人怎么会有一天醒来突然说：“嘿，你知道我在干什么吗？我要狠狠地虐待自己。”对。“我希望今天有人把我从楼梯上扔下去。”对，而且难道你——难道你不会经常浑身酸痛吗？不管怎样，你接着说。嗯，其实我确实有点酸痛，我实话实说，
but you know, I've been doing a lot, I do a lot of PT and I stayed, tried to stay healthy and I did get out earlier than some of my friends who are still calling me like, hey, I hear you got a movie going and I got a couple days for me on that show. Uh-huh. And you're like, you know, you're 50, dude,
but you know, I've been doing a lot, I do a lot of PT and I stayed, tried to stay healthy and I did get out earlier than some of my friends who are still calling me like, hey, I hear you got a movie going and I got a couple days for me on that show. Uh-huh. And you're like, you know, you're 50, dude,|||但你知道的，我做了很多，我做了很多物理治疗，并且我一直——尽量保持健康，而且我确实比我的一些朋友更早退出了这行，他们现在还在打电话给我：“嘿，听说你有个电影项目，在那部剧里给我留几天活呗。”嗯哼。而你会想，你知道的，你都 50 岁了，老兄，
you're not jumping out of the car. Yeah. But like, were you constantly, were your parents constantly driving you to the emergency room when you were a little boy? Were you always jumping off shit and hurting yourself? No, I actually came into the stump business right around the time everyone was like specializing. And so they were looking for like martial artists.
you're not jumping out of the car. Yeah. But like, were you constantly, were your parents constantly driving you to the emergency room when you were a little boy? Were you always jumping off shit and hurting yourself? No, I actually came into the stump business right around the time everyone was like specializing. And so they were looking for like martial artists.|||你又不能从车里跳出去了。对。但话说回来，你小时候，你的父母是不是经常开车带你去急诊室？你是不是总是一直从各种东西上往下跳然后弄伤自己？不，我其实是在大家开始走专业化路线的时候进入特技行业的。所以他们当时在寻找类似武术家这样的人才。
And I had, I competed in martial arts as a kid, and like all through college, and I was getting really excited about using this knowledge in movies, like, you know, because you learn so much in martial arts that's completely useless, let's be honest, like there's all these moves that don't work, and you're like,
And I had, I competed in martial arts as a kid, and like all through college, and I was getting really excited about using this knowledge in movies, like, you know, because you learn so much in martial arts that's completely useless, let's be honest, like there's all these moves that don't work, and you're like,|||我小时候参加过武术比赛，整个大学期间也一直在练，我当时对把这些知识运用到电影中感到非常兴奋，就像，你知道的，因为你在武术中学到了很多完全没用的东西，说实话，比如有各种根本不管用的招式，你会想：
why am I studying all of this stuff? And then you realize, oh, because I can make up a fight with it, and it can be really cool, and look cinematic. So there was a group of guys that I was competing with that were in LA and they were working on, you know, these bad blood sport movies and things like that. And I went and visited them in Mexico
why am I studying all of this stuff? And then you realize, oh, because I can make up a fight with it, and it can be really cool, and look cinematic. So there was a group of guys that I was competing with that were in LA and they were working on, you know, these bad blood sport movies and things like that. And I went and visited them in Mexico|||我为什么要学所有这些东西？然后你才意识到，哦，因为我可以凭此编排出一场打斗，而且可以非常酷，具有电影感。当时我在洛杉矶有一群一起比赛的朋友，他们在参与制作——你知道的，那些烂透了的《血点》之类的格斗电影。我去墨西哥探望过他们，
on the set of this movie called Perfect Target, starring Daniel Bernhardt. And I watched them put together fight scenes, jump off of stuff, and like, yeah, fall into pads. And I'm like, I'm in. I just like packed up my car and left. I was teaching second grade in Minneapolis. I had just graduated from college.
on the set of this movie called Perfect Target, starring Daniel Bernhardt. And I watched them put together fight scenes, jump off of stuff, and like, yeah, fall into pads. And I'm like, I'm in. I just like packed up my car and left. I was teaching second grade in Minneapolis. I had just graduated from college.|||在一部由丹尼尔·伯恩哈特主演的名为《完美目标》的电影片场。我看着他们编排打斗场面、从高处往下跳，还有，没错，摔在垫子上。当时我就想：算我一个。我直接收拾好车就出发了。我当时在明尼阿波利斯教小学二年级。我刚从大学毕业。
Wow, and you're like, instead of beating... They're like, where are you going? You're like, I'm going to be a stunt performer. Yeah, I'm like, moving to LA, I'm going to be a stunt man. And then, of course, nothing in this business is easy. And so I moved into a house in Redondo Beach, there were six of us, that we're all trying to be stunt people.
Wow, and you're like, instead of beating... They're like, where are you going? You're like, I'm going to be a stunt performer. Yeah, I'm like, moving to LA, I'm going to be a stunt man. And then, of course, nothing in this business is easy. And so I moved into a house in Redondo Beach, there were six of us, that we're all trying to be stunt people.|||哇，而你的想法是，与其打击……他们问：“你要去哪儿？”你说：“我要去当特技演员。”对，我说：“我要搬去洛杉矶，我要当特技演员。”然后，当然，这行里没有哪件事是容易的。于是我搬进了雷东多海滩的一栋房子里，我们有六个人，都想成为特技演员。
I mean, this is a show in its own brand. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And we dug a trampoline in the backyard without telling our landlord. We bought our pads, we bought an airbag, we went out to the desert, we built high fall towers. We were just going to train to be stunt people until somebody gave us a shot.
I mean, this is a show in its own brand. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And we dug a trampoline in the backyard without telling our landlord. We bought our pads, we bought an airbag, we went out to the desert, we built high fall towers. We were just going to train to be stunt people until somebody gave us a shot.|||我的意思是，这本身就是一个节目题材。对，对，对。我们在后院挖了个蹦床，没告诉房东。我们买了垫子，买了气垫，去了沙漠，搭建了高空坠落塔。我们打算一直训练成特技演员，直到有人给我们一个机会。
No way. And those, are you still friends with that group of people? Yeah, by the way, they're all really successful stunt coordinators, second year to directors. Chad Stahelski was the other guy. He directed John Wick with me. Yeah, you guys co-directed John Wick. That's amazing.
No way. And those, are you still friends with that group of people? Yeah, by the way, they're all really successful stunt coordinators, second year to directors. Chad Stahelski was the other guy. He directed John Wick with me. Yeah, you guys co-directed John Wick. That's amazing.|||不会吧。那群人，你现在还和他们保持联系吗？对，顺便说一句，他们现在都是非常成功的特技指导、第二摄制组导演。查德·斯塔赫斯基就是其中另一个家伙。他和我一起执导了《疾速追杀》。对，你们联合执导了《疾速追杀》。太惊人了。
We have a mutual friend too, the great Wade Allen, who we both adore. Oh yes, Wade. And he was around in the early years as well. Just love me, Wade Allen. Love Wade. Stupid question, but what's the biggest injury? Like what's, like you're like, okay, I'm out.
We have a mutual friend too, the great Wade Allen, which we both adore. Oh yes, Wade. And he was around in the early years as well. Just love me, Wade Allen. Love Wade. Stupid question, but what's the biggest injury? Like what's, like you're like, okay, I'm out.|||我们还有一个共同的朋友，伟大的韦德·阿伦，我们两个都很崇拜他。哦，对，韦德。他早年也在周围活动。我太喜欢韦德·阿伦了。喜欢韦德。问个愚蠢的问题，受过最严重的伤是什么？比如，哪一次你会觉得：好吧，我干不了了。
I can't do this. I'm out. This is a great one. So I'm thinking like, you know, the training ground for stunt performers is the live show. Right? And so I hadn't even done a movie yet or a TV show, but I was trying out for the Batman live show
I can't do this. I'm out. This is a great one. So I'm thinking like, you know, the training ground for stunt performers is the live show. Right? And so I hadn't even done a movie yet or a TV show, but I was trying out for the Batman live show|||我做不下去了。我退出。这个故事很精彩。我想的是，你知道的，特技演员的训练场就是现场表演。对吧？所以当时我甚至还没拍过电影或电视剧，但我正在为蝙蝠侠现场秀进行试镜——
at Magic Mountain. I was, by the way, trying out. I wasn't even the guy. And... To play Batman? To play Batman. Excellent. And I was showing off.
at Magic Mountain. I was, by the way, trying out. I wasn't even the guy. And... To play Batman? To play Batman. Excellent. And I was showing off.|||在魔术山。顺便说一句，我当时只是在试镜。我甚至都不是那个人。而且……去演蝙蝠侠？去演蝙蝠侠。太棒了。而我当时在炫耀。
I was like swinging from the, the car goes under this catwalk, I grab the bar and I'm supposed to do a back, well, I'm not supposed to do a back flip, but I'm going to show everybody how I'm going to do a back flip. Oh my God. Yeah, famous last words, hold my beer, right?
I was like swinging from the, the car goes under this catwalk, I grab the bar and I'm supposed to do a back, well, I'm not supposed to do a back flip, but I'm going to show everybody how I'm going to do a back flip. Oh my God. Yeah, famous last words, hold my beer, right?|||我当时从——汽车从那个猫道下方开过，我抓住横杆，我本该做一个后——好吧，我本不该做一个后空翻的，但我要向所有人展示我是怎么做一个后空翻的。哦，天哪。对，这就是著名的临终遗言：“帮我拿一下啤酒”，对吧？
And then it was like, I completely under-rotated, everybody how I'm going to do a backflip. Oh my God. Yeah, famous last words, hold my beer. Right. And then it was like, I completely under-rotate it, put my wrist down and I shatter it in four places. Oh my God. Wow, wow. I'm like, surgery, you know, I have a big halo on my wrist and you know, and it's super embarrassing because again, I'm not even a stunt man yet.
And then it was like, I completely under-rotated, everybody how I'm going to do a backflip. Oh my God. Yeah, famous last words, hold my beer. Right. And then it was like, I completely under-rotate it, put my wrist down and I shatter it in four places. Oh my God. Wow, wow. I'm like, surgery, you know, I have a big halo on my wrist and you know, and it's super embarrassing because again, I'm not even a stunt man yet.|||然后结果就是，我旋转严重不足，向所有人展示我是怎么后空翻的。哦，天哪。对，著名的临终遗言：“帮我拿一下啤酒”。对。然后就变成了，我旋转严重不足，手腕先着地，结果手腕碎成了四截。哦，天哪。哇，哇。我心想：要做手术，你知道的，我手腕上戴着个大固定支架，你知道的，这超级尴尬，因为还是那句话，我当时甚至还不是个特技演员。
I am just like the beginning of my career, trying to break into this business. Did you try to cover it up? And do you think like, oh shit, I'm not, I don't have what it takes because I broke my wrist? Like, is there part of you that, were you discouraged? I was embarrassed more than discouraged. I think, you know, there was a great group of guys
I am just like the beginning of my career, trying to break into this business. Did you try to cover it up? And do you think like, oh shit, I'm not, I don't have what it takes because I broke my wrist? Like, is there part of you that, were you discouraged? I was embarrassed more than discouraged. I think, you know, there was a great group of guys|||我正处于职业生涯的起步阶段，试图挤进这个行业。你当时试图掩盖它吗？你有没有觉得，哦糟了，我完了，我手腕断了，说明我不是这块料？比如，你内心深处有没有感到沮丧？与其说沮丧，不如说我感到尴尬。我觉得，你知道的，当时有一群非常棒的伙伴，
that we were all like, we just really believed it. You know, we really believed that we could make it. And part of it was this conversation we overheard in a diner, we always tell each other this today. It was pretty funny. There was two women in a diner sitting behind us and they were like, preparation plus opportunity equals miracles, sister.
that we were all like, we just really believed it. You know, we really believed that we could make it. And part of it was this conversation we overheard in a diner, we always tell each other this today. It was pretty funny. There was two women in a diner sitting behind us and they were like, preparation plus opportunity equals miracles, sister.|||我们都觉得——我们是真的很坚信这一点。你知道的，我们真的相信我们能成功。其中一部分原因是我们无意中听到餐馆里的一个对话，我们今天还经常互相提起这件事。挺搞笑的。餐馆里有两名女子坐在我们身后，她们说：“准备加上机会等于奇迹，姐妹。”
Preparation plus opportunity. And so we would, jokingly we'd always say that, but we really meant it. It's like just get good, just get good, and then someone will open the door and then you're good. And you get to do stuff. And so we would just train. All we did was train.
Preparation plus opportunity. And so we would, jokingly we'd always say that, but we really meant it. It's like just get good, just get good, and then someone will open the door and then you're good. And you get to do stuff. And so we would just train. All we did was train.|||准备加上机会。所以我们总是开玩笑地这么说，但我们是认真的。就像是只要变强，只要变强，然后就会有人为你打开大门，接着你就厉害了。你就能大展身手了。所以我们只管训练。我们唯一做的事就是训练。
I mean it's crazy, like Tron, which I love, Tron, the Bourne movies. It's crazy. Bourne Ultimatum, I mean, that is, what, I, there are very few movies that I watch on repeat and the Bourne movies are in there. Yeah, they're so good. There are like five, do you guys have like five movies
I mean it's crazy, like Tron, which I love, Tron, the Bourne movies. It's crazy. Bourne Ultimatum, I mean, that is, what, I, there are very few movies that I watch on repeat and the Bourne movies are in there. Yeah, they're so good. There are like five, do you guys have like five movies|||我的意思是这太疯狂了，比如《创：战纪》，我超爱这部电影，《创：战纪》还有《谍影重重》系列。太疯狂了。《谍影重重3》，我的意思是，那是——什么，我，我反复观看的电影极少，《谍影重重》系列就在其中。对，它们太棒了。大概有五部，你们有没有哪五部电影——
that you will repeatedly watch? I have the Bourne movies, Ronin, Midnight Run. A Midnight Run with Nail and I. That's it. Yeah. That's it. Midnight Run, so good. David, that's it. Yeah. That's it. Midnight Run, so good. David, what's sort of agreed upon as the,
that you will repeatedly watch? I have the Bourne movies, Ronin, Midnight Run. A Midnight Run with Nail and I. That's it. Yeah. That's it. Midnight Run, so good. David, that's it. Yeah. That's it. Midnight Run, so good. David, what's sort of agreed upon as the,|||是你会反复观看的？我有《谍影重重》系列、《浪人》、《午夜狂奔》。我和奈尔一起看的《午夜狂奔》。就这些。对。就这些。《午夜狂奔》，太棒了。大卫，就是这样。对。就是这样。《午夜狂奔》，太棒了。大卫，大家公认的——
when you say that the stuntmen sometimes now specialize, what is sort of the agreed upon hardest thing, that the high water for all stuntmen, is it driving stuff, is it firework, is it free falls? Is it, yeah. Well look, in the fall guy, we got to like, you know, sort of play homage to all the old school stunts, right?
when you say that the stuntmen sometimes now specialize, what is sort of the agreed upon hardest thing, that the high water for all stuntmen, is it driving stuff, is it firework, is it free falls? Is it, yeah. Well look, in the fall guy, we got to like, you know, sort of play homage to all the old school stunts, right?|||正如你所说，现在特技演员有时会进行专门的分工，那么大家公认最难的事情是什么，对于所有特技演员来说最高的标杆是什么？是开车特技、放烟火，还是高空自由落体？是——对。好吧，看，在《特技狂人》里，我们得以向所有老派特技致敬，对吧？
We did this like incredible car roll. Like, Tar Robinson. Yeah. And we did the high, we did a high fall, like, and that was Bob Brown's kid and who was a legendary high fall artist. Like that, that is really like the lost art. The high fall.
We did this like incredible car roll. Like, Tar Robinson. Yeah. And we did the high, we did a high fall, like, and that was Bob Brown's kid and who was a legendary high fall artist. Like that, that is really like the lost art. The high fall.|||我们拍了这种不可思议的翻车特技。比如，塔·罗宾逊。对。我们还做了高空坠落——我们做了一个高空坠落，那是鲍勃·布朗的孩子，他是一位传奇的高空坠落特技大师。这，这真的就像是一门失传的艺术。高空坠落。
Down into like, down into an airbag. Into an airbag. You don't see those anymore, right? Yeah, you don't. These are all cable drops now, isn't it? Yeah, we use, you know, visual effects lets us erase the wires and we can use high speed winches
直接掉到……掉到气囊里。掉进气囊。现在很少见那种镜头了吧？对，确实没有了。现在全都是用威亚吊落了吧？对，我们现在用，你知道的，视觉特效可以让我们把威亚擦掉，而且我们可以用高速绞盘
or we can use descender rigs and there's a lot of ways to do that, you know, in a safer manner. But like when we did it in the movie, we had Troy Brown come out, who's Bob's kid, and he's one of the few people that can do it, and has trained that old school sort of stunt. But look, it's such a wide discipline of stuff,
或者我们可以用降落索装置，有很多方法可以做到这一点，你知道的，用更安全的方式。但是就像我们在电影里拍的那样，我们请来了特洛伊·布朗，他是鲍勃的孩子，他是为数不多能做到这一点的人，而且受过那种老派特技的训练。但你看，这是一个非常广泛的学科，
and that's why you have to be specialized, because everything got more and more technical as we tried to make it safe. And so the drivers specialize in driving. But is there one stunt that exists in cinema, like in film, that is heralded as the stunt? Well, you know what you don't see anymore, and I wonder if this is the answer, is the fire gag.
这就是为什么你必须专业化，因为当我们试图让它变得更安全时，一切都变得越来越技术化。所以特技演员专门负责驾驶。但是电影里真的存在那么一个特技，比如在胶片中，被誉为“终极特技”吗？嗯，你知道现在已经看不到什么了吗，我在想这算不算，就是火人特技。
Like you never see somebody lit on fire anymore while walking around like, oh my God, put me out, put me out. I used to see that in every movie. Yeah, because they're in like a Michelin Man suit. Well, now there's like, they've invented this great gel. Actually, there's a stunt performer. He's got a company called Action Factory and he just won, or he was recognized by the Academy
就像你再也看不到有人身上着了火，然后四处走动喊着，哦天哪，帮我扑灭，帮我扑灭。我以前在每部电影里都能看到。对，因为他们穿着那种像米其林轮胎人一样的厚重防护服。嗯，现在有了一种，他们发明了一种很棒的凝胶。事实上，有个特技演员他开了一家叫“动作工厂”的公司，他刚刚赢得了，或者说他受到了学院的表彰
for a technical achievement award for his gel, this stunt gel that allows you to basically burn for a long period of time without the big suit and without the prosthetic mask. You just rub it on your body? Well, it's, there's the gel underneath it, but it's really the fuel that burns cooler. It's a combination of the water gel,
因为他的凝胶获得了一项技术成就奖，这种特技凝胶能让你基本上在不需要大厚衣物和假体面具的情况下，长时间忍受火焰燃烧。你只要把它抹在身上就行了？嗯，是这样，它下面有一层凝胶，但真正起作用的是那种燃烧温度较低的燃料。这是水凝胶的组合，
which is like an aloe-based gel, and then the fuel that burns cooler. But look, it's all like the circus. Like there's all these sort of secrets. Jay, what's that story from you when you were 18, you had to use a gel for burning. What was that? What was that whole thing?
它有点像芦荟基底的凝胶，然后搭配燃烧温度较低的燃料。但你看，这就像马戏团一样。有各种各样的秘密。杰伊，你18岁时有什么故事来着，当时你不得不使用燃烧凝胶。那是什么情况？那整个过程是怎么样的？
Hey, hey, hey. But is there, but I guess what I'm asking is, is there one thing that everybody uses as, you know, Jason said, you know, like there's a particular style of stunt that's the high water mark, but is there one performance, stunt performance, that everybody goes, that's the granddaddy of them all.
嘿，嘿，嘿。但是，或者说我其实想问的是，有没有那么一个东西是所有人都在用的，就像杰森刚才说的，你知道的，某种特定风格的特技就是最高水准，但是有没有哪个表演，哪个特技表演，让所有人都会说，那才是所有特技的鼻祖。
Somebody who did like a jump or a thing or a fall. What about that jump in one of the Bourne movies where the guy jumps from one building into another building through a side window. How do they do that? And camera follows him in. Yes, I think about that all the time. Yeah, it was pretty amazing.
某个做过某种跳跃、某种动作或某种坠落的人。伯恩系列电影里的那个跳跃怎么样，就是那个家伙从一栋大楼跳到另一栋大楼，穿过侧边窗户的那个。他们是怎么做到的？而且摄像机还跟着他一起进去。对，我经常想起那个镜头。对，太惊艳了。
It's really impressive. Matt must have loved it. I mean, you know, sitting there with his Dunkin' Donuts coffee in his hand. Go it again. He was already on a. Yeah, you know what? That with his Dunkin' Donuts coffee in his hand. Go it again. He was already on a... Yeah, you know what? That looks really fucking good from over here.
真的令人印象深刻。马特当时一定很喜欢。我是说，你知道的，手里拿着一杯唐恩都乐咖啡坐在那。再来一遍。他当时已经在……对，你知道吗？手里拿着一杯唐恩都乐咖啡坐在那。再来一遍。他当时已经在……对，你知道吗？从这里看，这特么效果太棒了。
Yeah, do it one more. Is there one where we can see his face a little bit less? That'd be great, just so people believe it's me. Fucking, I don't want anybody taking my credit. Tell him to fix his hair. You know Matt. You know how Matt is. He probably was sitting on first unit.
对，再拍一次。有没有哪个镜头能让我们稍微少看到一点他的脸？那样就太好了，好让大家相信那就是我。他妈的，我可不想让别人抢了我的功劳。告诉他把头发整理好。你了解马特的。你知道马特是什么样的人。他大概当时正坐在第一摄制组呢。
I mean, I don't know if we shot it on second unit. I can't really remember that, but yeah, it was a pretty amazing stunt. By the way, I drive Matt crazy with questions about the Bourne movies all the time. I make him insane. I ended up, Frank Marshall ended up giving me like a rap gift from the first one
我是说，我不知道我们是不是在第二摄制组拍的那个。我记不太清了，但总之那是个相当了不起的特技。顺便说一句，我经常拿有关伯恩系列电影的问题把马特烦得要死。我把他折腾疯了。最后，弗兰克·马歇尔甚至送了我一件第一部的杀青纪念品，
with the briefcase and the jacket and stuff because I wouldn't stop bothering him about it. How'd you guys do that? And then what did you do when you did that? Like, I'm so annoying, I love those movies so much. David, how do you feel? Are you excited about this? The Academy Awards are gonna...
里面有公文包、夹克之类的东西，因为我一直没完没了地烦他关于那部电影的事。你们当时是怎么拍的？然后你们拍那个的时候又做了什么？天哪，我太烦人了，我太喜欢那些电影了。大卫，你感觉怎么样？你对这个感到兴奋吗？奥斯卡奖将要……
Well, this is what I was gonna bring up. Us. This is David's, David has been leading the charge on this, Jason. Oh, no. No, not at all. David sort of really grabbed the reins on, and David, I want you to say it in your words,
嗯，这就是我要提的。我们。这是大卫的功劳，大卫一直带头在做这件事，杰森。哦，不。不，完全不是。大卫算是真正抓住了核心，大卫，我希望你用你自己的话来说，
but I want to tee you up. Tell Tracy what this is. Yeah, you have, it's a real breakthrough in entertainment and in our business. A new category in the Academy Awards. Yeah, yeah, look, it's been a long journey and look, for 20 plus years inside the Academy, there's been a lot of stunt coordinators working on it.
不过我想先给你做个铺垫。告诉特雷西这到底是什么。对，你经历过，这是娱乐业和我们行业的一次真正突破。奥斯卡奖增设了一个新奖项。对，对，你看，这是一段漫长的旅程，你看，二十多年来，在学院内部，有很多特技统筹一直在为此努力。
Jack Gill, Greg Smurs, Melissa Stubbs, there's been a lot of people trying to move the needle. And after, you know, we basically, we made Fall Guy, we're coming back from making Fall Guy, we are all feeling really excited about this giant commercial we made for why there should be an Academy Award for stunts. And I just went in with Kelly,
杰克·吉尔、格雷格·斯莫尔斯、梅丽莎·斯塔布斯，有很多人都在试图推动这一改变。在经历过，你知道的，我们拍完了《特技狂人》，我们拍完《特技狂人》回来后，我们所有人都对我们为“为什么应该设立奥斯卡最佳特技奖”而制作的这支巨型广告感到非常兴奋。我和凯莉一起去见了他们，
my wife and producing partner, we went in and talked to the Academy of like, what's been the stumbling blocks? How do we get this done? Casting found a way to get this done. How can we find a way to get this done? And they really did, there was a tremendous amount of support inside the Academy
我的妻子兼制片伙伴，我们去跟学院谈了谈，到底是什么在阻碍这一切？我们该如何促成此事？选角部门找到了实现这一目标的方法。我们怎么才能找到方法把它办成呢？他们真的做到了，学院内部有巨大的支持力度，
and they just said, look, we have a roadmap, you follow. And it's just been some sort of lack of clarity. And so Kelly and I really went down the road of like trying to rebrand what we were asking for. And I think, you know, the Academy obviously has these, this legacy of honoring design, like production design, costume design. And I think when people think stunts,
他们只是说，看，我们有一个路线图，你们照着走就行。只是以前缺乏某种清晰度。所以我和凯莉真的开始着手重新包装我们所要求的诉求。而且我认为，显然学院有这样一个传统，即表彰设计类的奖项，比如最佳艺术指导、最佳服装设计。我想当人们想到特技时，
they're like, what are you gonna give the stunt to the, you're gonna give the award to the performer, or are you gonna give the award to the person that rigged the stunt? And it's like, no, we're gonna give it to the stunt coordinator, the department head. The tradition is you give it to the designer. And so we rebranded our credit on the fall guy, and this was Kelly's idea, to stunt designer.
他们会想，你们要把特技奖颁给谁，是颁给表演特技的演员，还是颁给搭建特技威亚装置的人？结果大家发现，不，我们要把它颁给特技统筹，也就是部门负责人。传统的做法是把奖颁给设计师。所以我们在《特技狂人》中重新命名了我们的职衔，这是凯莉的主意，改成了“特技设计”。
And Chris O'Hara, the stunt coordinator on that, Kelly went to the guilds, she got it approved by the WGA and the DGA, I'm sorry, the DGA and SAG. And it was like, we got the credit stunt designer and that was sort of the first. That's really cool. Brian, now, and so now this year, the next Oscars stunts are gonna be recognized.
而该片的主特技统筹克里斯·奥哈拉，凯莉去了各个工会，她通过了美国编剧工会和美国导演工会的批准，抱歉，是美国导演工会和演员工会。结果就是，我们获得了“特技设计”的头衔，这可以说是开创了先河。这真的很酷。布赖恩，现在，所以今年，接下来的奥斯卡奖中特技将得到认可。
Or maybe not recognized. Well, it's gonna be two years, I think, that's kind of like we have some internal things to do in terms of like how it's gonna be awarded. And they wanna do it on the 100th anniversary. Do we know if that's gonna be a part of the primetime awards or is that gonna be the technical awards? I think it's all open for discussion
或者也许不会马上认可。嗯，大概需要两年时间吧，我想，因为我们内部还有一些关于这个奖将如何颁发的工作要做。而且他们希望在百年华诞时推出。我们知道这会是黄金时段颁奖典礼的一部分，还是说会归入技术类奖项？我想这一切都还在讨论中，
and really wasn't what we voted on this time around. But it's exciting. Like, look, I think it's long overdue and I was happy to be instrumental inside the academy, like really getting on the Zooms with all the governors I could and like really canvassing it. And then, you know, for our final vote, I curated a video presentation with a lot of director friends,
而且这确实不是我们这次投票表决的内容。但令人兴奋。你看，我认为这早就该发生了，我很高兴能在学院内部发挥作用，比如尽可能多地与我能联系到的所有理事进行Zoom视频会议，大力进行游说。然后，你知道的，为了我们最后的投票，我策划了一个视频演示，里面有许多导演朋友、
celebrity friends that were really advocates. curated a video presentation with a lot of director friends, celebrity friends that were really advocates for it. That's great. Well, honestly, David, kudos to you for doing it. I think it's awesome, and I think it's awesome that the Academy recognized it too, so kudos for them for that. And as we all know, and Jason, I've heard you talk about it before,
名人朋友，他们都是该奖项的真正倡导者。策划了一个视频演示，里面有许多导演朋友、名人朋友，他们都是该奖项的真正倡导者。太棒了。好吧，老实说，大卫，真为你做成这事点赞。我觉得这太棒了，而且我也觉得学院能认可这一点很棒，所以也要为他们点赞。众所周知，杰森，我以前听你谈过这个，
and we all know here on this, and people should know, everybody who's on set when you're there, everybody is a filmmaker at that point. Everybody is part of the filmmaking process. Right? There's no one there that doesn't need to be there. Exactly. Especially when it comes to rigging up a stunt
我们在这里所有人都知道，大家应该明白，当你在片场时，在那里的每一个人，在那一刻都是电影人。每个人都是电影制作过程的一部分。对吧？没有谁是在那里可有可无的。没错。特别是当涉及到搭建特技装置时，
is such, it's such serious work. It's so much safety and rigging. Yeah. And that recognition is long overdue to all the incredible stunt performers out there. So really, kudos to you, it's awesome. And yeah. That's great.
这是一项非常严肃的工作。需要考虑太多的安全和威亚搭建。是的。这种认可对于所有了不起的特技演员来说，真的是迟来太久了。所以真的，为你点赞，这太棒了。而且，是的。太棒了。
I have a question about like overall stunt work. Well, cause from Will and Grace. Yeah. There was some crack falls in Will and Grace. By the way, one of my entrances on the David Letterman. By the way, it says me, I don't do it. One of my entrances on David Letterman when he had his talk show,
我有个关于整体特技工作的问题。哦，因为从《威尔和格蕾丝》开始。对。在《威尔和格蕾丝》里有一些从高处跌落的惊险桥段。顺便说一句，我在大卫·莱特曼节目中的一次出场……顺便说一句，上面写着是我，其实根本不是我。当大卫·莱特曼主持他的脱口秀时，我的其中一次出场，
they let me jump off the balcony onto a... What? Yeah. Really? I jumped off the balcony onto, what is it called? Nice. Like a pad? Yeah.
他们让我从阳台上跳到一个……什么？对。真的吗？我从阳台上跳到那个叫什么来着的地方？太棒了。像个垫子？对。
Like it was filled with air? Like an air pad? Oh, like an airbag. Yeah, an airbag. I can't believe they let me do that. So David, go ahead, Sean. No, I was just going to say, so is it, by the way, that's whatever that is.
就像里面充了气的那种？像气垫吗？哦，就像气囊一样。对，一个气囊。我真不敢相信他们竟然让我那么做。所以大卫，你接着说，肖恩。不，我刚想说，所以，顺便说一句，管他是什么呢。
But is it true that- Oh, sorry, sorry, hang on. Yeah, no, no, I just meant like, I can't believe somebody let me do that and I wasn't even- Best stunt performance in a talk show appearance. There was no stunt coordinator on set. There was none.
但这是真的吗——哦，抱歉，抱歉，等等。对，不，不，我的意思是——我不敢相信有人让我这么做，而且我甚至都不是——脱口秀出场最佳特技表演。片场当时根本没有特技统筹。一个也没有。
Was there a bump? Did you get, George, did you just get the appearance fee or was there a stunt bump? Jason, you always did a bump before Letterman, didn't you? I always loved a good bump on Letterman. And not Letterman, but anyway. So, is it true, do you guys get, or the stunt people get paid every single take?
有额外津贴吗？乔治，你当时拿的是出场费，还是有特技津贴？杰森，你在上莱特曼节目之前总是有津贴的吧，对不对？我一向很喜欢在莱特曼节目里拿不错的津贴。虽然不是莱特曼，但不管怎样。那么，这是真的吗，你们这些人，或者说特技演员每次拍摄都能拿到报酬？
Is that right? It's not like a regular acting fee or whatever. Is it true that that's how they get paid? I heard that once. Well, that's a great, we can explain what bump means in the stunt world. Yes. So every time, well in the 80s it meant two things,
是这样吗？这不像常规的演员片酬什么的吧。这是真的吗，他们是那样拿报酬的？我以前听说过一次。嗯，这很好，我们可以解释一下特技界所说的“津贴”是什么意思。是的。所以每次，嗯，在80年代这意味着两件事，
I'm sure. It probably meant one, like how am I gonna get ready, and two, how am I gonna get paid. But it's really, it's called the stunt adjustment, and you get money for each time you do something that's dangerous and that's sort of, it's decided by the stunt coordinator in production and like sort of agreed upon.
我敢肯定。它可能意味着第一，我要怎么做好准备，第二，我要怎么拿钱。但这其实叫做特技调整费，每当你做一些危险的、由特技统筹和制片方决定并达成一致的事情时，你每次都能拿到钱。
And so yeah, if you did this, that stairfall I was talking about in Fight Club, he was probably getting $500 each time on top of his salary. David, I like the idea that he's like, hey man, listen, my kid needs new braces. Do I just throw me down a couple more times? Yeah. Fuck it up.
所以，是的，如果你拍了这个，我在《搏击俱乐部》里说的那种滚下楼梯的镜头，他每次除了基本薪水外，可能还能额外拿到500美元。大卫，我挺喜欢这种设想的，就好像他在说，“嘿，老兄，听着，我孩子需要一副新牙套。我多摔几下行不行？”对。把它搞砸。
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. You mentioned that your wife is your producing partner. Yeah. Talk to us about that.
对。完全正确。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你提到你的妻子是你的制片伙伴。对。跟我们聊聊这个吧。
That's awesome. I mean, how long you've been doing that? I mean, the fact that you never have to be separated because so much of what we do necessitates a separation from your family and I know Boohoo, these are high class problems, but it is kind of tough. It's so great, it sounds like you guys get to stick together all the time, talk to us about that.
这太棒了。我是说，你们这样合作多久了？我是说，你们永远不用分开，因为我们所做的工作中有很大一部分需要与家人分离，我知道这有点矫情，这些都是有钱人的烦恼，但确实挺艰难的。这真的很棒，听起来你们可以一直黏在一起，跟我们聊聊这个吧。
It really is actually, so we've been married 12 years and it's been amazing. Like look, we met a little later in life and that was great. She's just. Was she a producer when you met her? Yeah. Is that how you guys met?
实际上确实如此，我们结婚12年了，感觉一直棒极了。你看，我们相遇得稍微晚了一点，这很好。她只是……你们认识的时候她就是个制片人吗？对。你们就是那样认识的吗？
She came, she worked with Scott Rudin's company and then she ended up in LA and she is 100% responsible for me becoming a director. I will give her all the credit. So she sort of, she wasn't a manager, but she hip pocketed Chad and I when she was working at this company called Sierra Affinity, which is a foreign sales company,
她来过，她曾在斯科特·鲁丁的公司工作，后来她去了洛杉矶，我能成为一名导演，她百分之百居功至伟。所有的功劳我都归于她。所以她算是在某种程度上，她当时不是经纪人，但当她在一家名叫塞拉·阿芬蒂的外海销售公司工作时，她把查德和我“私藏”了，
and she was curating their slate of projects. And she was like, I'm going to get you guys, and Nick Meyer, the guy that owned that company, allowed her to do that. And so she really taught us how to take meetings and really was a champion to the agencies about these guys direct action, but they also tell stories. And she was like a big advocate for us
她负责挑选他们公司的项目储备。她当时说，我一定要签下你们俩，而拥有那家公司的尼克·迈尔允许她这么做。所以她真的教会了我们如何去开会，并且在各大经纪公司面前极力为这些家伙争取——他们不仅能拍动作戏，而且还会讲故事。她就像是我们的坚强后劲，
and she ended up finding John Wick. It came through Sierra Affinity's office and she sort of slipped it to Chad and I and she's like, you guys should meet on second unit and then you should pitch yourselves as directors. Because it's all action. And then- Was that your first film as a director?
最后她发现了《疾速追杀》。这个剧本送到了塞拉·阿芬蒂公司的办公室，她悄悄把它塞给了查德和我，她说：“你们应该去参与第二摄制组的会议，然后把你们自己推销为导演。”因为这全都是动作戏。然后——那是你作为导演的第一部电影吗？
Yeah. And was that the first John Wick? The first John Wick, yes. Wow. Keanu Reeves is notoriously very picky and snobby in the best way about directors, as is Brad Pitt. Like these guys just work in director vehicles, even though they're enormous stars
对。那是第一部《疾速追杀》吗？第一部《疾速追杀》，是的。哇。众所周知，基努·里维斯对导演非常挑剔，可以说是以最好的方式挑剔，布拉德·皮特也是如此。这些人只接导演有才华的电影，尽管他们是超级巨星，
and can work in and create star vehicles and just get any director that'll listen to whatever the hell they want to do, they don't do that. They love to work for it. So what a huge compliment that you ran through whatever gauntlet creatively through Keanu who's so discerning, that's awesome. Yeah, he was incredibly supportive from the beginning.
完全可以打造自己的明星专属电影，并且只要他们愿意，可以找任何愿意听他们差遣的导演，但他们不这样做。他们喜欢为优秀的导演工作。所以，你能通过基努那挑剔眼光在创意上的重重考验，这是多大的赞誉啊，太棒了。是的，他从一开始就给予了极大的支持。
And he is, you're right, he's like a director's actor, like he loves the director. And we had worked with him for so long on the Matrix sequels. And we had trained him for those sequences. And Chad was actually his- So he was familiar with you guys. Yeah, and he- That's great.
而且他是，你说得对，他就像是个“导演型的演员”，他热爱导演。我们和他一起合作《黑客帝国》续集很长时间了。我们为那些动作场面训练过他。查德实际上还是他的——所以他很熟悉你们。对，而且他——太棒了。
And then we had helped with choreography on Man of Tai Chi, something that he directed. And so we were like, we maintained that relationship and friendship. So then when it came up, hey, there's a lot of action in this movie. We'd love to be considered. And we put together our presentation, our lookbook,
然后我们在他执导的《太极侠》中帮忙做过动作编排。所以我们一直保持着那种合作关系和友谊。因此，当这个项目出现时，嘿，这部电影里有很多动作戏。我们很希望能被纳入考虑范围。于是我们做好了演示文稿、概念图册，
our sort of, you know, our character sketches and our arcs. And we pitched it to him. He said, let's go to Lions Gate and tell him you want to do it. Wow. Do you ever see yourself, Dave, do you ever see yourself doing something kind of moody and small and talky just as a gear shift?
还有我们的，你知道的，角色草图和人物弧光。我们向他做了推销。他说，我们去狮门影业告诉他们你想拍这部电影。哇。大卫，你有没有想过，比如为了转换一下风格，去拍一些情绪化、小成本、台词多的作品？
Yes. Yeah, do you? You have a script you want to submit, Will? Yeah, if you want. It's real talky, it's just me basically talking. It's in a room. It's hard because I have so much fun. Since Deadpool, everything's had a real fun tone.
会。对，你有吗？威利，你是不是有个剧本想投递？对，如果你愿意的话。台词超多，基本上就是我在那儿说话。场景就在一个房间里。这很难，因为我拍得太开心了。自从《死侍》之后，所有的作品都带有一种真正欢乐的基调。
And I do enjoy comedy. That's why I'm, not only the reason, but I'm a huge fan of all your work, all you guys. You're just so fricking funny. And that's why we have to do something together, please. The Smartless Stump movie, I see it now. Let's do it. Where you just throw me down the stairs and that's it.
我也确实很喜欢喜剧。这就是为什么我不仅是原因所在，而且我是你们所有作品、你们所有人的超级粉丝。你们真的太他妈有趣了。这就是为什么我们必须一起合作点什么，求你了。我脑海里已经浮现出 Smartless Stump 电影的画面了。我们拍吧。就是那种你们把我从楼梯上扔下去就完事了。
Over and over and over. By the way, before you get into it, because I want to hear your answer of what you want to do. Just to remind our audience, the films that you've done, that you've directed, just that you've directed, John Wick, Atomic Blonde, Deadpool 2, Hobbs and Shaw, Bullet Train, Fall Guy. Like these are.
一遍又一遍，没完没了。顺便说一句，在你切入正题之前，因为我想听听你想做什么样的回答。只想提醒一下我们的听众，你拍过的电影，你导演过的电影，仅仅是你导演过的作品：\\《疾速追杀》\\、《极寒之城》\\、《死侍2》\\、《霍布斯与肖》\\、《子弹列车》\\、《特技狂人》\\。就像这些……
I know these are all big cinematic, you know, event movies that people love to go with. Just to remind our listener, these are the movies that you love. This is. And the degree of difficulty is super high. It's super high. So having said that, so you've done these big movies
我知道这些都是宏大、你懂的、人们乐于去影院观看的电影盛宴。只想提醒我们的听众，这些都是你喜爱的电影。这就是。而且难度系数超级高。超级高。话虽如此，既然你拍过这些大制作，
that take a lot of planning and a lot of resources and figuring, so do you see yourself making a? Something simpler, yeah, no. Well, I do, I mean, look, the fun moments for me right now, it's not the big action sequences. I mean, again, I love making them, but they're the sort of like earnest, dramatic moments. You know, I think into the Fall Guy, like some of the scenes
需要大量筹备、大量资源以及各种算计，那你觉得自己会去拍一部……更简单的作品吗？对，不会。呃，其实会的，你看，对我现在来说，有趣的时刻已经不是那些宏大的动作场面了。我的意思是，再次声明，我热爱拍那些，但它们更像是那种走心的、戏剧性的时刻。你知道的，我觉得在《特技狂人》里，比如有些场景，
with Ryan and Emily that are really sort of emotional. Both such good actors. Yeah, and like watching those, collaborating with those great actors and like bringing some real humanity to the screen, I think separates, if I pat myself on the back for a second, I think it separates what, you know, people go to see my movies because they're big action movies
瑞恩和艾米莉之间的戏份真的非常具有情感张力。两人都是那么优秀的演员。对，看着这些，与那些伟大的演员合作，并在银幕上注入一些真正的人性，我认为这区分开了——如果我稍微自我夸奖一下的话——我认为这区分了人们，你知道的，人们去看我的电影是因为它们是大动作片，
and there's subversive comedy and all that, but they remember them because they love the characters so much and it's because you actually cared about them. Right. Well, I think, and it goes to David also, like how I kicked it off, which is you are such a great guy and you are such a, you are a very thoughtful person. And so it doesn't surprise,
里面有颠覆性的喜剧等等，但他们之所以记住这些电影，是因为他们太爱这些角色了，这是因为你真的在乎他们。没错。嗯，我觉得，这其实也回到了大卫刚才说的，就像我是怎么开头的，那就是你真的是个极好的人，你是一个非常体贴的人。所以这并不奇怪，
it wouldn't surprise me if you did something leaning more that way. And you're right, your movies do have those elements in it. So it'd be cool to see. I think you'd be really good at it. Yeah, I would love to do a straight up drama. I think right now I'm actually in Pittsburgh and I'm prepping the next movie.
如果你拍一部更偏向那种风格的作品，我也不会感到惊讶。你说得对，你的电影确实包含这些元素。所以看到那种作品会很酷。我觉得你真的很适合拍那种。是的，我很想拍一部纯粹的剧情片。我想我现在其实在匹兹堡，正在为下一部电影做前期筹备。
It's called How to Rob a Bank. And it is sort of a new, you know, taking a heist movie and turning it on its head. And I have Nick Holt and Pete Davidson. Amazing. That's awesome. There's a lot of dramatic elements in this project that was why I'm attracted to it.
片名叫《如何抢劫银行》。它有点像是一种全新的，你知道的，颠覆传统劫案电影的作品。我有尼古拉斯·霍尔特和皮特·戴维森加入。太棒了。那太赞了。这个项目里有很多戏剧性元素，这也是为什么我被它吸引。
Yeah, talk about that for a sec. Like, would you have been as excited earlier, earlier that a project like this sort of led with, you know, just sort of, you need to be able to talk actor bullshit lingo, and you need to be able to talk fucking, you know, lighting and editorial pace. But do you know what I mean? Like how was that a comfortable transition for you
对，聊聊这个吧。早先时候，你是否也会对这样一个项目如此兴奋——那种开场就是，你知道的，你得会说演员圈里的废话黑话，你还得会说他妈的，你知道的，灯光和剪辑节奏。但你知道我的意思吗？就像，对你来说，这算是一个舒服的过渡吗？
or not transition, was it a comfortable process for you to learn and get as familiar with talking actor or talking gaffer or talking camera operator as it was talking stunts? Like was that one of the big things that was like, oh, you know, I can coordinate a fight, but the other part of this directing stuff is being able to like help an actor kind of find a moment
或者说不上过渡，对你来说，去学习并熟悉演员的行话、灯光师的行话、或是摄影机操作员的行话，像熟悉特技行话那样自然，是一个舒适的过程吗？就像，这是不是那些重大的事情之一，让你觉得“哦，你知道的，我可以协调一场打斗，但导演工作的另一部分是能够帮助演员找到某个情绪点，
or talk to, you know, the gaffer about, you know, what the lighting strategy might be in this thing. Talk about that stuff. Or tell Jason Baben that his wig is slipping off. You know what I mean? Yeah, you gotta take him to the side, you know? Because no one knows. No one's gonna tell, yeah.
或者跟灯光师讨论，你知道的，这里的灯光策略可能会是什么样的。”聊聊这些吧。或者告诉杰森·巴本他的假发快掉了。你知道我的意思吗？对，你得把他拉到一边去，你知道吗？因为没人知道。没人会说，对吧。
Well, I will say, yes, you get better each time out. And I think, but I did, you know, I had, for better or worse, I had the training wheels of second unit. And so with second unit, you're still working with actors. And like, you know, a movie like this, you know, this blockbuster Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles that Will and I worked on.
嗯，我得说，是的，你每一次都会做得更好。而且我觉得，但我也确实——不管好坏——我有第二组（导演）的辅助轮。所以在第二组里，你依然在和演员合作。而且就像，你知道的，像这样的一部电影，你知道的，这个由我和威尔合作的大片《忍者神龟：变种时代》。
Like, I mean, I worked with- It was a blockbuster. It was a blockbuster. It was. Number one for three weeks, go ahead. It was. We, I worked with Will, you know,
我的意思是，我合作过—— 这是一部大片。 这是一部大片。 确实是。 连续三周票房第一，你接着说。 的确是。 我们，我跟威尔合作过，你知道的，
I got to work with actors and we were working on performance even inside the action. So you were constantly like, you were learning actor speak at that way, at that, at that well. Right, right. But then, you know, obviously sitting in the first unit chair becomes, it's a different animal, but I felt really, really comfortable from the get-go. But I think it was having years of like,
我有机会和演员合作，而且我们在动作戏里面也一直在打磨表演。所以你一直在，你通过那种方式、那种源泉学习演员的语言。对，对。但随后，你知道的，显然坐上第一组导演的椅子，这就成了完全不同的概念，但我从一开始就感到非常非常舒服。不过我想这是因为有了多年的积累，
being a second unit director, getting more and more, a bigger piece of the film each time out, you know? Like these big commercial films, like you might have like six weeks of second unit. It's a lot. And that's more than we had to shoot John Wick, the first movie. like you might have like six weeks of second unit. It's a lot. And that's more than we had to shoot John Wick,
做第二组导演，每一次都能获得电影中更大、更多的份额，你知道吗？就像这些大型商业片，你可能要在第二组呆上大约六周。这可真不少。这比我们拍《疾速追杀》第一部时的时间还要多。就像你可能要在第二组呆上大约六周。这可真不少。这比我们拍《疾速追杀》第一部时的时间还要多。
the first movie. That's wild. What would folks listening who are not in this business, what part of the process as a director would they be surprised to hear is really not enjoyable, not really pleasant? Is it sort of the start of things, like sort of pitching, trying to describe
太疯狂了。对于那些不在这一行当里的听众来说，作为导演，流程中的哪一部分会让他们听到后觉得真的很不享受、很不愉快？是事情的开端吗，比如在办公室里坐着时，向那些制片厂高层进行推销、试着描述你打算拍什么？
what you're going to do to these studio heads when you're sitting in an office? Or is it marketing it, like talking to the press afterwards about what to expect? There's so many different parts. Is there a part that's particularly unpleasant to you or a part that you're still kind of getting used to or making friends with?
还是说营销它，比如事后跟媒体谈论该对影片抱有什么期待？有太多不同的部分了。有没有哪个部分对你来说特别不愉快，或者你还在习惯、还在试着与之融洽相处？
I mean, getting them off the ground is always the hardest. I think. Yeah. It's just... Selling. Selling it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And like, getting people involved
我是说，让它们从无到有地启动总是最难的。我觉得。是的。就是…… 推销。 推销它。对，对，对。还有让人们参与进来，
and getting their schedules right and like getting your key collaborators to believe in it. But even once you've sold it, just from the, even once they say yes, people involved and getting their schedules right and getting your key collaborators to believe in it. Even once you've sold it, even once they say yes, even from the yes to first day to actually showing up, you're like, right to the end, right? You're like, we're supposed, because never a hard green light.
理顺他们的档期，让你的核心合作伙伴相信它。但即使在你把它推销出去之后，哪怕在他们点头同意之后，让人们参与进来，理顺他们的档期，让你的核心合作伙伴相信它。即使在你把它推销出去之后，即使在他们点头同意之后，从答应的那一刻到第一天开机再到真正现身，你会发现，直到最后一刻，对吧？你会想，我们本该——因为从来没有真正的亮起全绿灯。
Are we greenlit? Are we greenlit? Are we greenlit? And you're working on the budget. The week before, they're like, it's kind of are we greenlit? Are we greenlit? And you're working on the budget, like the week before, they're like, it's kind of approved budget, right? Explain a little bit how that works. Yeah, they say they want to make it for something
我们亮绿灯了吗？我们亮绿灯了吗？我们亮绿灯了吗？而且你还在做预算。就在前一周，他们还会说，这算是——我们亮绿灯了吗？我们亮绿灯了吗？而且你还在做预算，就像前一周那样，他们会说，这算是获批的预算，对吧？稍微解释一下这是怎么运作的。对，他们说他们想用多少钱拍一部片子，
and then you get it into that box and then you have a creative idea. And then it's like, that's a great idea. And then you're like, yeah, the money box. And then it's like the box expands and then you try and get it back in. And it's constantly like trying to hit a number, whether it's a $100 million movie
然后你把项目塞进那个框子里，接着你又有了一个富有创意的想法。然后他们就会说，那是个好主意。接着你就会想，对啊，还有资金的框子。然后这个框子就像是会膨胀，而你又得试着把它塞回去。这就像是在不断地试图击中一个目标数字，不管是1亿美元的电影，
because there's all these expectations that drive those costs up, or it's a $25 million movie like these ones that we produce that, you know, they're never agreeing that. Nobody's coming out, nobody two is coming out in August. That's another exciting. That's so psyched. Nobody but the great Bob Odenkirk who we all know very well.
因为有所有这些推高成本的期望，还是像我们制作的那些25部的、你知道的，他们从来没完全同意过。没有人的续集要在八月上映了。这又是另一个令人兴奋的消息。太让人兴奋了。除了伟大的鲍勃·奥登科克，我们大家都非常熟悉他。
I just saw him on stage at Gary Glen Ross. I did too, Jay. I just saw, how great is he? My God, was he great, yeah. So great. Oh my God. He's amazing. He's so good and nobody two, I'm really excited about it.
我刚在舞台上看过他的《推销员之死》。我也看过，杰。我刚刚看到，他有多棒？天哪，他太棒了，对。太棒了。哦，天哪。他太令人惊叹了。他太优秀了，对于《无名之辈2》，我真的超级期待。
We've had, we had a great time making it. I was actually one of those where Kelly produced it, but I was on set quite a bit. It was really fun. Like we were super. Isn't that Sean, that's your handle on Grindr is just nobody, right? That's correct, yeah.
我们拍得很开心。其实凯莉是制片人之一，但我经常在片场。真的很有趣。就像我们超级—— 肖恩，那是你在Grindr上的账号名，就叫“无名之辈”，对吧？ 没-错，是的。
And just my photos are just the neck down. So you don't get a lot of downtime to just go travel or do anything. I mean, it seems like you just go project to project to project. Right now, it's been that, the last 10 years has been pretty busy, I have to say. Like this is movie number seven.
而且我的照片只有脖子以下的角度。所以你没有太多闲暇时间去旅游或做任何事。我的意思是，听上去你就是从一个项目接着一个项目地连轴转。目前来看确实如此，过去的这十年一直非常忙碌，我必须得说。就像这是我拍的第七部电影。
And then plus the ones we produced, a violent night with David Harbour and the nobody with Bob. So, but again, I love it. I guess I kind of grew up, it said my adult life was all physical production. I loved it. I loved the set life. I loved my fellow friends on there.
再加上我们制作的其他片子，比如和大卫·哈伯合作的《暴力街区》以及和鲍勃合作的《无名之辈》。但是，再次声明，我热爱这一切。我想我差不多是在这种环境中长大的，我的成年生活全都是实打实的物理制片。我爱死它了。我热爱片场生活。我爱我在那儿的伙伴们。
I love like waking up eating the bad burrito and like, how do we get this done? Like, so I miss it. It's been two years since we were on set. Oh, no way. With Fall Guy. Really? Yeah, so for me it's like I'm ready to dig in
我喜欢醒来吃着难吃的卷饼，然后思考：我们怎么把这事搞定？所以我想念它。我们离开片场已经有两年了。哦，不会吧。拍《特技狂人》的时候。真的吗？对，所以对我来说，我已经准备好大干一场，
and shoot some stuff. How are you liking Pittsburgh? What have you found up there in Pittsburgh that you're liking to do? Honestly, we play pickleball. Oh yeah? Good. Have you experienced any life scarring injuries
拍点东西了。你在匹兹堡过得怎么样？在匹兹堡，你发现有什么喜欢做的事情吗？说实话，我们打匹克球。哦，是吗？不错。你有因为匹克球受过什么留下心理阴影的伤吗？
from pickleball? Cause you can really read who's who. I know. Yes, I knew somebody that works in the ER just recently. She said most of the people that come in here because of pickleball. Oh, it's brutal. David, no offense, I'm not a fan.
因为你真的能看出谁是谁。我知道。是的，我最近认识一个在急诊室工作的人。她说来这儿看急诊的人大部分都是因为打匹克球。哦，太惨烈了。大卫，无意冒犯，我不是它的粉丝。
I'm not a fan of pickleball. You're not? Did you play tennis? You're a tennis? I'm a purist, I just, I don't know. I think of pickleball, it's a fat man sport. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Can you, there's even places to play racquetball anymore? I love it. When you find them, you're like, oh my God, look at that big white room. Yeah, I really made it.
我不是匹克球的粉丝。你不是吗？你打网球吗？你是个网球…… 我是个纯粹主义者，我只是，我不知道。我觉得匹克球是胖子的运动。哈哈哈……你还能……现在甚至还有地方打壁球吗？我太喜欢了。当你找到它们的时候，你会想，天哪，看看那个巨大的白色房间。是的，我可真行。
I like squash, because it was harder, you know what I mean? And you had to go running. Yeah, but there's a very unsatisfying sound and hit. How dare you say that about squash? We almost enjoyed it immensely. So you're playing a lot of pickleball, which is good. Yeah, our nephews go to Carnegie Mellon.
我喜欢壁球，因为它更难，你知道我的意思吗？而且你得跑来跑去。对，但击球时的声音非常不爽。你怎么能对壁球说这种话？我们几乎喜欢得不得了。所以你经常打匹克球，这挺好的。对，我们的侄子在卡耐基梅隆大学上学。
That's how we have used. And so it's been odd like being here, they're both in college and we're now here on prep. And it's like, hey, you guys wanna hang out? It's Saturday night. And they're like, uh, we're in college. Yeah, and you're 50. Yeah, exactly.
这就是我们为什么会在这儿。所以在这里感觉怪怪的，他们俩都在上大学，而我们现在在这里做前期筹备。然后就变成了：嘿，你们想出来玩吗？今天是周六晚上。而他们会说：呃，我们在上大学呢。对，而你50岁了。对，没错。
And you're 50, yes, exactly. And you're 50? Yes, exactly. Well, again, David, I just want to say, I want to reiterate how cool it is what you've done for the stunt performers. Really cool. To bring them, you know, yeah, to get them recognized and that the Academy did that is really awesome. And so congrats to everybody.
而你50岁了，是的，没错。你50岁了？是的，没错。好吧，再次声明，大卫，我只想说，我想重申你为特技演员所做的一切是多么酷。真的太酷了。把他们带到聚光灯下，你知道的，是的，让他们得到认可，学院能这么做真的太棒了。所以向大家表示祝贺。
And again, another testament, what a great dude and what an awesome guy and what a great director you are that you've become and increasingly, it's just so fucking rad. I'm happy to know you and continued success, my friend. You're just the best. Yeah, it's great to have talked to you for a bit about all this, man.
再次证明，你是个多么棒的家伙，多么了不起的guys，你成长为了一名多么出色的导演，而且越来越优秀，这简直太他妈酷了。很高兴认识你，祝你百尺竿头更进一步，我的朋友。你真的是最棒的。对，能跟你聊一会儿这些事真是太棒了，老兄。
Thank you for doing this. Thanks for having me on. Yeah, man, it's been so fun. Send my love to Kelly, if you will, this. Thanks for having me on. Yeah, man, I really appreciate it. This has been so fun. Send my love to Kelly, if you will, please. I will. Yeah, and we'll talk to you really soon, and have a great time out there in Pittsburgh. I appreciate it.
谢谢你做这些。谢谢邀请我上节目。对啊，老兄，真的太有意思了。替我向凯莉问好，如果你愿意的话，这个。谢谢邀请我上节目。对啊，老兄，真的非常感谢。这真的太有意思了。替我向凯莉问好，如果可以的话，求你了。我会的。行，我们很快再聊，在匹兹堡玩得开心。谢谢。
Enjoy the rest of your weekend. See you, bye. Cheers, pal. You too. Bye, bye. Bye. That was a great guest there, Willie. Yeah.
好好享受剩下的周末。再见，拜拜。保重，老兄。你也是。拜拜。拜。那是个很棒的嘉宾，威利。对。
How's it going? Really super guy. I'm such a fan of his. I'm really stoked it worked out and that the sketch worked out and he's such a great guy and I have had the pleasure, we also made a commercial together that hasn't aired for a bunch of reasons, and it was something that, it was great, but we didn't really have to do much and we were just on a stage for three days at Paramount. Yeah, he seems like a really fun hang.
最近怎么样？真的是个超级棒的人。我是他的超级粉丝。我真的很高兴事情顺利进行，那个小品也很成功，而且他真的是个很好的人，我有幸——我们还一起拍过一个由于各种原因一直没播出的广告，那感觉挺不错的，其实我们没做什么，只是在派拉蒙的摄影棚里待了三天。是的，他看起来是个相处起来非常开心的人。
So we just kind of hung out for three days, and we did this thing, it was fine, and the people were really nice, and we did a nice thing, but I just got to spend an additional three days with him like four months ago, and it was so great. He's such a good, thoughtful dude. I think we should workshop what the Smartless movie would be that we can pitch to him.
所以我们就在那儿闲逛了三天，拍了这个东西，效果挺好的，大家也都很好，我们做了一件不错的事，但我大概在四个月前又跟他多相处了三天，真的太棒了。他是一个那么好、那么体贴的家伙。我觉得我们应该头脑风暴一下，构思一部什么样的Smartless电影可以向他推销。
It should be stunt intensive. Well, of course. The three of us get kidnapped by the disgruntled listener. Yeah. And we're tied up in the back of a van. The disgruntled listener and Sean is held hostage at the donut factory. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, I'm back in, I'm back in.
应该充满特技元素。嗯，当然。我们三个被一个心怀不满的听众绑架了。对。我们被绑在一辆面包车的后座上。那个心怀不满的听众和肖恩被扣为人质关在甜甜圈工厂里。等等，等等，等等，等等。哦，我又加入了，我又加入了。
It is just to keep him fucking quiet. He's got a dozen donuts in his mouth the entire movie. By the way, by the way, the last day, our last day, mine and Scotty, because Scotty's in Will's movie as well, we sent donuts to everybody on set. They did. Huh.
这纯粹是为了让他他妈的闭嘴。整部电影里他嘴里都塞着一打甜甜圈。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，最后一天，我和斯科特的最后一天——因为斯科特也参演了威尔的电影——我们给片场的每个人都送了甜甜圈。他们确实送了。哈。
They did. They sent donuts, and then I asked him if he'd had any, he said of course, and then I had a great moment, I will say, I won't say where, but I had a great moment, there was this big, Sean and Scotty sent this, I won't say where, but I had a great moment. There was this big, Sheldon Scott, he said this, I don't know, like 30 boxes of donuts on this big table. And at one point I see like four cops standing over it.
他们送了。他们送了甜甜圈，然后我问他有没有吃过，他说当然吃了，然后我经历了一个很棒的时刻，我要说的是——我不说在哪里——但我经历了一个很棒的时刻，当时有这么大一个——肖恩和斯科特送了这个，我不说在哪里，但我经历了一个很棒的时刻。有这么大一个——谢尔顿·斯科特，他送了这个，我不知道，大约有30盒甜甜圈摆在这个大桌子上。然后我看到有四个警察站在它旁边。
And I didn't have my phone, I was like, where's my fucking phone? It's real. I know, it was pretty good. They were great guys. David's great though, you know what the one thing? Here he comes. No, no, no, this isn't it yet.
我当时没带手机，心想：我他妈的手机呢？是真的。我知道，这挺搞笑的。他们都是很好的人。不过大卫真的很棒，你知道唯一的一点是什么吗？他来了。不，不，不，还不是这个时候。
But I did want to ask him because he does seem so level-headed and like really cool, like you're saying. He is really cool. Really like down to earth. And Jay, you're the same way I imagine on set where you're just, but it's like those types of personalities that are like just down to earth and have to keep everybody happy on a set. What do you do when you get so fucking pissed
但我确实想问问他，因为他看起来真的很冷静，而且真的很酷，就像你说的。他真的很酷。真的很脚踏实地。杰，我想你在片场也是这样，你总是——但就是那种性格的人，他们就是很脚踏实地，还得在片场让所有人都开心。当你对一个人或某件事感到他妈的超级愤怒时，你怎么办？
about a person or something? How do you stuff it? And then how does it come out later? Well, let's ask Amanda, cause she's usually, she bears the brunt of most of the frustration. Wait, wait, wait, it's a shot. I was sorry, I was actually reading something.
你是怎么把情绪压下去的？然后这情绪后来又是怎么爆发出来的？嗯，我们去问阿曼达吧，因为她通常——她承受了大部分的沮丧情绪。等等，等等，这算是个回击。对不起，我刚才其实在看别的东西。
All right. Say that one more time. Oh my God. No, no, wait, Sean, I was sorry, I was actually reading something. Say that one more time. Oh my God. No, no, no, honestly, we just got a pitch for a bye. But what was it? Did you say when somebody says something that you don't like, how do you keep your page? No, no, no, like you guys have personalities where you have to, you're very level headed and you have to keep the piece on set all the time. And when somebody or something really pisses you off, you can't let it out,
好吧。再说一遍。噢我的天哪。不，不，等等，肖恩，我很抱歉，我刚才其实在看别的东西。再说一遍。噢我的天哪。不，不，不，说实话，我们刚刚接到一个关于……的点子。但那是什么？你是说当有人说了你不喜欢的话时，你怎么保持页面？不，不，不，就像你们有这样的性格，你们必须，你们非常冷静，而且你们必须时刻在片场维持和平。当有人或某事真的惹恼了你，你不能发泄出来，
so how do you let it out later, or what do you do about stuffing all that? Yeah, I know, I mean, I am not perfect with this, I'm sure some will attest, but I guess you just, like in anything, like you or Will or anybody else in this world, you just hope that you have managed your day properly leading up to that point where you are living
那么你后来是怎么发泄出来的，或者对于压抑这些情绪你有什么对策？是的，我知道，我的意思是，我在这一点上并不完美，我相信有人可以作证，但我想你只是，就像在任何事情中一样，就像你或威尔或这个世界上的任何人一样，你只是希望你在达到那个点之前已经妥善安排好了你的一天，那时你生活在
in a place of patience and compromise that you need to sort of, yeah. Yeah, there just must be so many things that are just like, what the fuck? Like all day long when you're directing, like when anybody's directing. Why aren't you just mad yourself right now? You're already worked up.
你需要的那种耐心和妥协的境界中，可以说是这样的。是的。真的会有那么多事情让人觉得，搞什么鬼？就像你当导演的时候整整一天都在发生，就像任何人当导演一样。你现在为什么不自己生闷气呢？你已经很激动了。
I know, because I feel like I would be that way, that's why. It is part of the job though, right? It is part of the job to manage all the incoming. You're going to raise your hand for a leadership position. There's a lot that comes with it, so unless you can do it all, keep from ending up. You know what it is I think that you got to do?
我知道，因为我觉得我会是那样的人，这就是原因。不过这也是工作的一部分，对吧？处理所有涌入的事情是工作的一部分。你要举手争取领导职位。随之而来的是很多责任，所以除非你能胜任这一切，并避免最终……你知道我觉得你得做什么吗？
I think that in those moments moments when you have that stuff, no, you just gotta be calm and you gotta think about what certain people would do, like historically people who are good. So you think about great people and thing, you might think about this and you think about God. And whenever you do, you can always look it up in the Bible.
我认为在那些你拥有这些东西的时刻，不，你必须保持冷静，你必须想想某些人会怎么做，比如历史上面面俱到的大人物。所以你会想到伟大的人和事，你可能会想到这个，你还会想到上帝。每当这个时候，你总能在圣经里查到。
Whatever you do, you can always look it up in the... BIBLE! Or you might need to just bite your tongue. Don't waste that one! BIBLE! Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
无论你做什么，你总能在……圣经里查到！或者你可能需要咬紧牙关。别浪费那个！圣经！聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。
Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjarff, Bennett Barbico and Michael Grant-Terry. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
聪明。绝顶。SmartLess 是由罗布·阿姆贾夫、贝内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特-特里100%有机手工打造的。聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。
Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝顶。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。